e
today is Thursday February 27th 2025
this is the the New Hampshire House of
Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power and the committee has
convened today for public
hearings now please make sure that your
cell phones are silenced and please join
us in reciting the Pledge of Allegiance
representative frock this is my second
time okay
well representative col is not here I
had her
down to the of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
all thank you and before we begin today
so the committee has convened today at
900 a.m. for public hearings on 11 bills
after the public hearings scheduled at
1:10 the committee will break for lunch
and then public hearings will resume at
o'clock
okay in order to stay on schedule today
the chair will allow for up to five
minutes for Bill introductions followed
by questions and answers and also up to
three minutes will be given for inperson
public testimony with the additional
time allowed for questions and answers
if the speaker allows and vice chair um
will keep track of the time and if time
has expired if we need to implement this
based on the number of pink cards that
we get the vice chair will hold up a
pink card indic ating that your time is
close to being expired at which time we
would like you to wrap up your testimony
if that happens and the speaker has
additional testimony that they would
like to share or additional information
please indicate that to the committee
and then follow up with um written
communication via email to the committee
and additionally if a speaker has
written testimony please um let us know
that so and distribute it um via
representative Walker today and so all
committee members can get your written
testimony if you have that and have the
um proper number of
copies and additionally for people
providing inperson testimony when you
take the seat please State for the
record your name who you represent and
your position on the bill and there's a
little laminated checklist as a reminder
okay okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on
hb200 and you should also have an
amendment to that bill uh
0538 got uh three speakers if anyone
else wants to speak please fill out a
pin card and give it to a representative
Walker and he'll send it down to the
chair uh the committee now calls
representative Diane
Power Morning
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 200 for your
consideration for the record I am
representative Diane power I represent
the towns of Brooklyn Mason and
Greenville in Hillsboro County District
36 and I also serve as a chairman of the
house Municipal and County government
committee House Bill 200 was filed upon
the request of a number of our
constituents across the state New
Hampshire law allows a political
subdivision of the state whose
legislative body raises and appropriates
funds through an annual meeting to adopt
a local tax cap and this is under RSA 32
colon
5-c a 35ths majority is required to
adopt a local tax cap under current law
the legislative body can override a
local tax cap by a simple
majority therefore a local tax cap is
simply a maximum starting point for the
tax effort which a governing body or an
official budget committee can bring
forward at an annual meeting for all
warrant articles that have a tax
impact the tax effort is the total
Appropriations minus the total estimated
revenues in other words under current
RSA a local tax cap simply limits the
total proposed tax
effort because the legislative body can
override this by a simple majority vote
so this bill is very simple it modifies
the vote threshold from a simple
majority to a three-fifths majority in
order to override a tax cap since the
purpose of a tax cap is to ensure fiscal
responsibility and prudence in budgeting
it is reasonable that any proposed
spending that causes the tax effort to
exceed the tax cap should in fact have a
higher standard to override than just a
simple
majority due to the fact that a tax cap
majority and also
requiring a requiring a 3- fths majority
to override it ensures that any spending
that exceeds the tax cap is in fact
supported by a super majority of Voters
we can all agree that increased local
property taxes is a major concern for
our constituents across the state and
this is our increasing taxes is due to
increase both Municipal and school
spending at the local level
therefore since overriding a tax cap
will increase the local tax effort which
of course results in increased local
property
taxes it is reasonable to require a
higher bar to override
it additionally I'd like to note that a
higher bar of a three-fifths majority is
required for bonds notes and multi-year
Lease agreements without an escape
Clause due to the extra extraordinary
Financial commitment that comes with
these types of
expenditures to be clear any increase
spending that overrides a local tax cap
is is similar to such an extraordinary
Financial commitment for the taxpayers
and
therefore the co-sponsors believe that
this should also require a 35ths
majority
vote I'd also like to point out that the
provisions of this bill in front of you
are very similar to the provisions of
2021 Senate Bill 52 which is now law
this law requires a super majority vote
for City Charter exclusions and
ordinances that have the effect of a tax
cap override since City C tax caps have
a super majority override requirement it
only makes sense for towns Village and
School District tax caps to similarly
also have a super majority override
requirement thus this bill House Bill
200 would align all other political
subdivisions with cities regarding
overriding a tax cap so that our laws
are consistent across the state also
House Bill 2 200 outlines that when a
proposed appropriation will exceed the
tax cap voting on the question shall be
by ballot
and lastly it's important to note that
this bill in no way limits the
legislative body's authority to either
increase or decrease the amount of any
single
appropriation or the total amount of all
Appropriations to conclude I urge that
the committee recommend House Bill 200
ought to pass with Amendment thank you
Mr chairman that concludes my bill
introduction
and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you representative power
representative R
gri thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question can you just
clarify um the last section B where on
line 20 down um on the assigned portion
when it goes into the assigned portion
of the adjusted sa shall be assumed and
raised as appropriate can you just
explain that a bit further thank you for
the question so in the amendment um that
change it eliminates simply eliminates a
reference in the bill that was filed to
194c due to the fact that there's um
that's not the only way to have an SAU
budget warrant article school districts
can optionally have an SAU budget
warrant article so that's why that was
amended
as
such any other
questions thank you representative thank
you like to Now call uh excuse me rep uh
Association thank you uh Mr B chairman
and thank you to the committee for the
record my name is Brody Dees I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and we are currently opposed to the bill
as introduced I haven't seen the
amendment so I can't speak to that but
I'll speak to the um what is the current
underlying bill um House Bill 200 uh
requires a tax cap override by the
legislative body to be done by ballot
even at traditional Town meetings and
the balloting will be done by a secret
yes or no ballot it also mandates that
SP SP2 municipalities and traditional
Town meetings must vote in a
three-fifths majority to override the
tax cap rather than the existing
majority vote um the decision whether to
appropriate more than the tax cap
belongs to the voters so this curbs
existing voter Authority and majority
rule by requiring a th higher threshold
um there's a separate Senate Bill I'd
like to point out that allows
municipalities to adopt a local option
tax cap that would have a
35 um option of overriding tax caps um
this overrides house buil 200 would
override the existing Provisions for tax
cap overrides and municipalities which
means the bill overrules the decisions
made by the legislative bodies the
voters any municipality with an existing
tax cap would automatically have to
implement this new override provision uh
with no revote requirement usually when
you introduce um sorry usually it's been
historic in Hampshire that when new
provisions of law for whether tax cap
overrides or other things that will
impact the budget process um that you
have some kind of voter adoption
procedure especially for tax caps notice
most of our tax caps in RSA 32 have some
kind of provision for voters to adopt um
the specific sections of it or to choose
which tax cap that uh is best for their
municipality um we believe that this
would be detrimental to the voters and
local control because of that reason
that by mandating um one type of
override um in in this specific set of
statutes that um that the voters have
lost control over how exactly they want
their budget process to to operate um I
also want to include that it includes
the firste cost of unapproved bonded or
multi-year warrant articles in the tax
cap calculation um under uh Roman 3
subsection a of the bill um which would
be a change and um and this also changes
kind of the concept of what is proposed
to the legislative body versus what the
legislative body has approved so
currently as um as was previously
mentioned um the tax cap is essentially
what the governing body you know a
limitation on what they post to the
legislative body um this would add a
further restriction on the legislative
body to determine how much it wants to
raise an appropriate in taxes either
more less the same amount as a governing
body and um we believe that the ultimate
um will of the voters should be left to
the legislative body and that majority
rule um should be what determines how
much is raised and appropriated in uh in
in municipalities budgets um and with
uh thank you Mr Dees uh any questions uh
representative Dolan please thank you Mr
Vice chair I I have a process question
yep if if at the annual
meeting uh the voters are approving
different changes amendments or
whatever but individual amendments don't
add enough to the budget to uh to exceed
the tax cap that they may have
previously agreed on at what point and
as there as the as the uh Community is
adding the scenario I'm thinking of is
they're adding elements P you know
pieces of of the government
expenditures uh and and then at some
point you might
trigger exceeding the tax cap uh let's
let's say say there there are five
amendments and it it isn't until you get
to the fifth amendment that all of a
sudden you've just triggered the
percentage maximum in the tax cap H how
does that work I mean do do you have to
go back and negate every amendment that
that contributed to that excess amount
of spending or do is it only the one
that triggers the excess so at a
traditional town meeting under current
law um the voters once so the governing
body they're the ones who are inhibited
from proposing a budget that exceeds the
tax cap calculation depending on what um
what parts of the state law you're
operating under and what type of tax cap
you've adopted their job you know their
responsibility what they're Bound by law
to do if they've adopted tax cap
Provisions in their uh municipality is
to introduce a budget that um meets
those um that meets the the requirements
of the tax cap in their municipality the
legislative body currently it can DEC
increase the budget by as much as it
wants it can increase the budget by as
much as it wants it's ultimately the
will of the voters and especially at a
traditional town meeting they can't
leave until they've approved the budget
now at s SP2 town There's a deliberative
session so the first session of the town
meeting and yes they're allowed to amend
the budget to surpass the amount of the
tax cap to decrease it um ultimately
once the budget's with the legislative
body um you just need a majority to pass
the budget and an SP2 you know after the
deliberative session and the budget has
been amended it's presented to the
voters and the voters can say yes to
that budget that was amended at the
deliberative session or no and if they
say no there's a default budget
calculations that's um that's you know
in state law and RSA 40 I want to say
colon 13 or 14 So currently it's the tax
cap Provisions are a requirement of the
government governing body representative
but not a requirement placed upon the
legislative body because they're the
voters and ultimately the taxpayers who
will have to um who will have you know
determine how much they want to have
raised in appropriated in their
municipalities and how much taxes they
thereof followup rep Dolan thank you uh
so at the town meeting the go the
members of the of the uh legislative
body uh the Govern governing body is
present and if if are they limited under
this under these Provisions to make
amendments to the budget uh to increase
the the budget I mean uh members of the
governing body who are present they can
raise their hand and get the attention
of the moderator and say I I want to
amend the budget increase it by X perc
or x amount of dollars are they limited
by this at all or or are they just
another member of the legislative body
are you saying specifically under this
Bill yes um so the way we interpret the
way we understand in this bill is
they're not prohibited from amending the
budget but if they as you mentioned if
they amend the budget and they surpass
that tax cap threshold in order to pass
the budget requires a super majority 3-
majority any other
questions represent majority
please thank you Mr Vice chairman and I
may be asking the same question it's not
it's not typical that the town meeting
deliberative session I I'm I'm in an SP2
Town increases the budget by substantial
amounts it did happen this year in my
town um there was a question about
overtime uh there was a there was a uh a
heated debate about that and the
increase was
significant so to to maybe piggyback on
what representative Dolan was saying the
increase in my town would have been 19%
of that line which if we had a tax cap
that and it pushed it over the tax cap
we would have needed three-fifths of the
deliberative session of the attendance
of the deliberative session to override
the tax cap to approve that increase not
at the deliberative you would need
three-fifths at the second session so to
pass your
budget so at the deliberative you could
you could amend your budget as you know
representative dlan alluded to you can
amend your budget however you want and
the legislative body can still amend it
um to surpass the tax cap but to pass
your budget you would need a super
majority so at a traditional town
meeting you couldn't leave until you
have um either a super majority of any
budget proposed by the legisl or every
budget amended by the legislative body
that surpasses the tax cap amount or a
regular majority if it doesn't surpass
the tax cap amount and at SP2 you would
amend it at deliberative and if it
surpass the tax cap amount um you know
the tax cap calculation you would need
three-fifths to pass the budget um at
Murphy thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for taking my question I thought there
was a
10% uh you only can raise the budget by
10% at delibera OB session no that might
be because your community has adopted a
tax cap provision and that's the
provision is 10% there is a percentage
option of the tax caps um this would
mandate one um
one type of override process for all tax
caps um but it wouldn't impact the
locally adopted you know whether it's a
dollar figure tax cap or a percentage
figure tax cap or I believe now in state
law there's even tax caps where you can
inflation any other
questions seeing none thank you mras
please thank you members of the
municipal and County government
committee my name is Eric power I'm from
Brookline representing myself just a
little bit of my background um I
currently serve on the Brookline
planning board I'm in my fifth year I uh
serve as the president of a organization
called the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire uh I
previously served a three-year term as a
school board member on the Hollis Brook
line Cooperative school
board and uh we also have a local tax
cap in Brookline School District right
now um I'm speaking in support of this
bill and let me talk about a few reasons
I think it's a good thing so for local
local towns right now the only tax cap
you can adopt is under RSA 325b and the
adoptions under
325c um with the change in law last year
there are three methods within that that
you can choose one's based on a fixed
percentage one's based on a fixed dollar
amount and one is based on an inflation
based index you can choose anything from
the US Bureau of Labor Statistics or the
municipal cost index then it also just
based on change in population in the
town if it's a town tax cap or uh
attendance uh
admr average daily membership and
residents for school districts so those
there's only really the one RSA that
allows the local Town tax
caps right now currently there's six
towns and two school districts in New
Hampshire that have adopted uh the local
tax cap and as was mentioned earlier the
local tax cap to pass it is not an easy
thing to do it's requires a three-fifths
U majority vote at the district
meeting the the thing that's that's
disappointing with the tax cap is that
even though a super majority voted to
have it a simple majority can vote to
override it and that's uh that's the
challenge and that's what this attempts
to fix because if you look at all the
tax caps that are available in City they
all have a super majority either a 2/3
or a 3- fths uh super majority override
so it makes a lot of sense to have that
for the towns and school districts as
well the
uh there was a question about the
10% um earlier the 10% rule is actually
not related to tax caps it's independent
of tax caps it has to do with an
official budget committee so if you have
an official budget Committee in your
town or School District
that would limmit the amount that the
legislative body can go up and that's
not part of the tax cap it's separate um
if you have an official budget committee
if you don't have one you don't have
that limitation or that ceiling I'd like
to also mention that the legislature
does change laws over time where the uh
school districts and towns do not have
to reopt the provisions uh when they
change and uh a prime example of that is
our s SP2
official ballot system of meeting that
that was first done in
1995 I believe and it's changed many
times and so over the years uh towns and
school districts that have adopted SP2
you know they keep the they they go with
whatever the changes are to the
legislature by yourselves as elected
representative decide to change there's
no read-option needed so that that
that's not necessary also we change uh
that the legislature changes things on
tax credits and others that don't
necessarily require
read-option so um I'd like to mention so
the the idea of the tax cap I can answer
more questions on this later but when
you have a tax cap in a traditional
meeting you have your prior years you
know Ms 736 737 for towns in the ms26
and 27 for school districts that tell
you what the tax effort was from the
previous year and what the tax efforts
proposed for this year so you know as
you're going through your annual meeting
when you're approaching that tax cap and
when the moderator and the clerk see
that a proposed vote on an appropriation
will exceed the tax cap they will make
that go by ballot secret ballot so that
you can determine the Three-Fifths
majority um so that's how that works in
a traditional meeting and in sb2 town
the deliberative and School District the
the school district uh in the town they
just they put things on the warrant so
at a deliberative session you're
preparing things for the official
balloting session that happens on
Election Day and so all of the three-
fifths is determined by what passes and
what doesn't based on the order of the
warrant articles on the uh on the ballot
so it matters how how the warrant
articles are uh ordered for when the
three fifs kicks in and then you just
determine whether to apply the 3- fifths
or to apply the simple majority
depending whether you're over or under
the tax cap on that particular warrant
article I'd like to also mention in the
uh hb2 200 amendment that um under
Section A it talks about the uh if your
operating budget is the one that is
going over the tax cap that if you pass
it by three fifths whatever is proposed
will will be adopted but if it passes
with a simple majority but not the not
the three- fifths maj majority the
adopted budget will be truncated to uh
to the whatever the tax cap Max is same
thing with the default budget if the
default budget in some towns is higher
than the proposed budget the default
budget goes over and it doesn't get the
three- fifths and it won't because you
wouldn't be getting a default budget
You' only get that if you get a simple
lower lower than a simple majority that
would also be truncated so there's the
operating budget is going to be
compliant with the tax cap there's not a
a way around it so that that's what the
purpose of this is to really ensure that
when you have spending that exceeds the
tax cap that it's agreeable to a super
majority of the voters and not just a
simple majority so um for those reasons
uh I I urge you to support uh this bill
ought to pass with Amendment and I'll
take any
questions thank you Mr power any
power representative gr thank you Mr
chair and thank you taking my question
um one of the in pieces in here on line
20 School District shall place the
warrant article for the SAU budget the
beginning of the school district warrant
immediately after warrant article
proposed by bonds or
notes I'm kind of curious on what your
opinion is because when if you do bonds
and notes first the tax impact is
typically pretty high and then you're
going to put the SAU so everything is
going to probably fall outside of tax
cap immediately but I'm curious on what
your opinion is on whether that would be
affective budgets or not thank you for
the question representative grund so
when you're doing a bond or a note
you're doing an authorization to do a
bond but you're only appropriating the
first year payment so that if you had a
bond of $2 million you might have
$200,000 uh first year payment or you
might even be smaller than that that
would be the one that would be counted
for the purposes of the tax cap not the
entire Bond um for those aren't aware
school districts can have optionally a
uh warant article for the SAU budget
there's some that do if you have a
there's a difference between a single
District SAU which is which is an seu
that serves just one school district and
then there are saus that serve multiple
school districts and I am in a
multi-district SAU in sau41 we have
three school districts within the SAU So
currently um
you can adopt a procedure under RSA 194c
to have a ballot vote that's enabling
legislation we actually have adopted
that in our district so we have a we
have a separate warn article in every of
the districts that uh to vote on that
and because of the um because of that
nature of it it needs to be first
because it's very unlikely that bonds
and notes are going to exceed the tax
cap if you're only looking at the
appropriation for the first year which
is what the the tax cap is looking at
that's what you list uh when you're
doing a bond or note you you list the
tax impact for the first year uh on the
MS
forms any other
questions certainly go ahead thank you
um so yes the first year right it's the
interest the second year if that Bond
passes that payment's now in there and
that's where the impact hits um
so it's you're going to hit that tax cap
really
fast and it's I don't know I'm I'm
concerned about the misleading nature of
always making the bond first
um because you typically school school
boards get to decide the placement and
Order of the warrant
articles thank you for the question I
think it was a question the um the once
the bond is passed it is typically not a
warn article in following years it
usually the bond payment becomes part of
the operating budget so that would be
part of the operating budget warnant
article it's only the first year when
the uh bond is proposed that it's
article repres majority thank you Mr
Vice chair and thank you for taking my
question um I'm not a school board
person so this question may not even
apply but in a Cooperative School
District where you have a collective
bargaining agreement if one of those
communities has a tax cap we have five
that that are in our Cooperative if one
of those school districts has a tax cap
and the collective bargaining agreement
would push that one school district
over
theirs what's my
question is there is there a problem
could there be a problem if only one of
those communities has the tax cap and
then this pushes them over and they
cannot override the tax cap and then the
entire collective bargaining agreement
would fail do do you see where I'm going
even though I'm not really asking a
question or is it not even
appropriate uh thank you representative
maiori I think I understand it so tax
caps are adopted by individual school
districts so if you had like the exiter
cooperative
a Regional School District they could
adopt a tax cap um in our town we have
the Brookline School
District which is K through six and then
we have and that has a tax cap and then
we have a separate Hollis Brookland
Cooperative School District which are is
grades 7 to 12 that does not have the
tax cap they're two separate political
entities so what we have for the
Brookline School District doesn't affect
the co-op vice versa so it's they're
done individually so they're they're
really independent so if the if your
larger District adopted the tax cap and
it and the CBA went over then that would
be something would need the override in
order to support it if it was if that
was the article that went over the tax
cap if it went before the operating
budget then if the operating budget went
over um that would be where the
Three-Fifths would kick in hopefully
when there's budgeting under a tax cap
the whole idea of a tax cap is so that
you plan so that your budget doesn't go
over the tax cap and you wouldn't even
need the override mechanism that's the
whole idea is people want the uh the
budgets to stay reasonable underneath
them representative
gr thank you Mr chair so I think I know
piece of where you might be going with
this so in Cooperative school districts
so I'm so heagan I have Amhurst and Mont
Vernon and if we had a tax
cap we had there's two different tax
rates that get calculated for each town
so what is that let's say you have a 2%
tax cap 2% is different for Amherst and
it is for Mont Vernon you present one
budget but what happens when you exceed
one what happens if it does Super do you
see where I'm going like you can really
start
affecting budgets with tax that tax cap
and calculating the tax rate in each
town and where does your budget fall out
potentially if it
passes thank you for the question I I
believe it's SE 39 so my understanding
sau39 has three school districts it has
the mount fernon School District it has
the ammer school district and it has the
Sagan Cooperative School District so
each one of those uh is an independent
entity with their own budget their own
governance their own annual meeting
their if they have SP2 their own ballot
um and I think there is SP2 there if I
remember so if sa heagan decided to
implement a tax cap it would only limit
the tax effort and it could be
overridden for the Sagan school district
and being a school board member from The
Cooperative I'm very familiar with this
that in so you're looking at the tax
effort for the whole saan school
district for example so if you have a
tax cap that that keeps you to $12
million for a number and you
um you want to exceed that it's it's
that's that what's the voters can do
that it's one single tax cap but after
the tax effort is determined and voted
upon whether it goes over the tax cap or
not that goes through the apportionment
formula that you have in your articles
of agreement for your Cooperative School
District so it's the tax effort for the
co-op is limited but when you apportion
it to I think Amherst and Mount
Vernon the tax effort might be higher
for Mount Vernon than it might be but
the net effort for the whole school
district and a co-op would be limited by
the tax cap and and that was where you'd
have to have the override so in a school
district it's possible that you could
obey the tax cap and some would still be
above the tax effort they get a
portioned is higher that's just the way
Cooperative school districts work and
there are problems with Cooperative
School District that's a whole another
issue but it's it's really the
conglomerate of the whole budget for the
co-op that's considered for the tax
effort the apportionment happens after
the fact based on the apportionment
agreement okay any other questions for
Mr
power seeing none thank you for coming
Mr power thank you also Mr Po is our
last speaker is there anyone else who
wants to talk to the committee and give
hb200 seeing then I'll close the public
hearing and I'm going to open a hearing
for HB
374 374 which is Rel relative to
clarifying reference under the local tax
on the uh blue sheet we have uh one
200 representative power you'd like to
introduce uh HB 374 to
us thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 374 for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
and Greenville in Hillsboro County
District 36 this bill is a housekeeping
bill to make Corrections and
clarifications in 2024 Senate Bill 383
which was signed into law last year so
some issues were identified as towns and
school districts began applying the new
local tax cap and The New School
District budget cap during this um 2025
annual meeting season the goal of House
Bill 374 is to ensure that all towns and
school districts have a clear
understanding of how the local tax cap
and the School District budget cap are
proposed adopted and then how they
function to Briefly summarize current
RSA the local tax cap law which is under
um 32 colon 5B and 32 colon
5-c that was updated to add a new method
for annually Computing the tax cap which
is based on an inflation index and the
change in the populace which for school
districts would be the change in the
number of students and for towns it is
the change in the town's population the
School District budget cap law um RSA 32
colon 5-e and RSA 32 colon 5-f is brand
new the budget cap is based on an
adopted cost per student each year the
budget cap is computed as the current
cost per student times the number of
students annually the current cost per
student is updated based on
inflation so um as you see there is an
amendment um to um House Bill 374 and
you should have that at your um desk
225-5787 Bill 383 three this amendment
also adds and corrects important
references to other rsas including those
for population and average daily
membership in residents
admr the amendment adds missing
statutory ref warrant article language
for certain cases the amendment
clarifies that an existing tax cap can
be modified by adopting a new tax cap
and the same applies also for budget cap
and also this amendment changes the the
date that the annual inflation index is
used from January 1st to October 1st so
that that infl inflation index change is
available for the budgeting process
which occurs um typically starting in
August fall so uh an additional handout
I I um prepared a a side by side and
it's pretty comprehensive it's a table
that um Compares like I said side by
side current law and what the amendment
is doing so yeah the amendment replaces
the bill that was filed because as we
went on um there were issues that that
arose that um made sense to put in to to
this bill um in an amendment so and so
as you can see I have current law the
amendment and also the last column on
the right is comments which does
describe um what the amendment does over
the current law so um to conclude I urge
that the committee recommend House Bill
374 a housekeeping Bill ought to pass
with amendment that concludes my bill
introduction and I'm happy to go over
thank you representative any questions
power seeing none thank you very much
thank
you okay our last speaker will be uh Mr
thank you committee members good morning
uh my name is Eric power I am from
Brookline and I'm in support of this
bill um HB 374 is a really important
bill uh to
clarify uh the local tax cap law and the
new School District budget cap law uh
these were new Bills new a new law last
year uh that took effect October first
based on Senate Bill
383 and these B the School District
budget cap and the local tax cap have
both been um very uh utilized this
budget season it's going on now there's
been many proposals for local tax caps
and School District budget caps across
the state and as as these are being used
there's questions about um some of the
references some of the uh RSA
references and so the the purpose of
this bill is to try to get the
legislature to clarify the bill so that
everybody has a common understanding of
what the local tax cap does how it works
and how's it how's it adopted and how is
it supplied and similarly to the um
School District budget cap the same the
same uh challenge um notably there's um
on row 10 of this table that was handed
out there's a uh there was missing uh
statutory language that being used uh
that should that's being used but it's
not in the law and that's important to
add um there are also better references
to what an what the uh admr is it
actually references rsa1
19838 so that people know where to look
for that it it also clarifies how the
under the School District budget cap how
the current per people costs work
some have interpreted it to be the uh
the one reported by the Department of
Education and this clarifies that it's
not it's the one that's defined here in
in the law um
and it it does a few other important
things uh one of the major things that
came up with the school district budget
cap is there in the budget season they
the inflation index was tied to how it
had changed as of January 1st turned out
that did not be that was not the best
date for that to make it October 1 made
a lot more sense because that then you
have the number by about mid October in
order to plan your budgeting in
compliance with the uh the new inflation
based local tax cap or the School
District budget cap so moving that to
October 1st makes sense October 1st is
also the date where the uh average daily
membership in school districts is
reported so it makes it more practical
makes it easier for people to work
there's at least uh one school district
karge I believe that actually has a
charter and they had their deliberative
session like on the 3 of January so they
didn't really have the number they
haven't adopted the School District
budget cap but if they were to it would
be challenging they would they would
have to figure that out so moving it
back to October 1st helps everyone and
makes things work very well I think
these two bills um this bill that
updates the local tax cap law and the
School District budget cap law are very
helpful for New Hampshire City
uh excuse me towns and school districts
and Village districts because I think it
helps the voters put in some guard rails
for spending and I think there's a
concern across the state about the
increase spending in both municipalities
and school districts and this is a a
good fiscal tool to help guide uh School
boards select boards and budget
committees to uh more sustainable
budgets and we also do not want to
create uh litigation among on um School
among among governing bodies and and
voters because of the law not being
clear and that's the whole purpose of
this is to avoid that so that it's very
clear to everyone what the intent of the
law is and how it works so for those
reasons I recommend otpa on House Bill
374 and I'll take any
questions thank you Mr poers any
poers seeing none thank you for coming
in
okay that was the last card that I had
for our speakers does anyone else want
to give testimony before the committee
374 okay seeing that I'll close the
hearing our next uh hearing will be at
local
e
1020 and going to call the uh committee
to order and we're going to take
138 okay uh our first speaker will be uh
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 138 local for
the record I am representative Diane
power I represent the towns of Brook
line Mason in Greenville in Hillsboro
County District
36 under current law enabling statute
allows that the legislative body of a
town or a school district District um
may vote to require that a tax impact
statement is included on every warrant
article the tax impact statement is
determined by the governing body and
this is under RSA 32 budget preparation
and the notation under current law need
only state the tax impact for the
upcoming fiscal year only while this is
sufficient information for most warrant
articles with one-year expenditures in
the case of Warrant articles with
multi-year expenditures the required
information is
incomplete moreover in the case of
Warrant articles for bonds showing only
the firste cost is especially incomplete
since the firste costs and tax impacts
are often quite small first year bond
costs are typical partial year interest
only payments and sometimes the first
year costs are zero since payments may
not start until the second year for
example a recent School District bond
warrant article listed a tax impact of 5
cents per
thousand and the taxpayers voted upon
that Warren article in that Associated
Tax impact information only to be
surprised at a much higher cost for Bond
payments in subsequent years so the
solution is House Bill 138 which
addresses this deficiency by simply
requiring uh notations stating the
estimated tax impact for any special
warrant article with a multi-year tax
impact or a warrant article that
contains a lease agreement with a non
appro without a non-appropriation
clause for the first 5 years or for each
year if the T tax impact is less than 5
years so by including this information
full disclosure in transparency is
enhanced and available to the voters so
that they can make a fully informed um
decision on their
vote um and this also affords the voters
um information about both the near term
as well as the long-term tax impacts of
the warrant articles that they're voting
on so for these reasons I urge the
committee to recommend House Bill 138
ought to pass that concludes my bill
introduction Mr chairman and I'm happy
to take
questions reference majority please I
thought Dale was going to go thank you
Mr Mr Vice chairman thank you for taking
my question so uh I'm trying to figure
out how the community is going to be
able to assess the tax impact in year
two three four or five when they don't
know anything about revenues or uh the
impacts of a revaluation which would
have have to happen every five years so
how could there be accuracy even though
you say estimate how could there be any
transparency to the community about what
the impact will be thank you for the
question representative as I said it it
is an estimate based on the information
that they do have and I think that that
whatever not whatever I think that the
information that can be provided and
printed on the warrant is far
superior um knowing that it's that's
that it is an estimate it's far superior
than no information at all so I
personally don't see a problem with that
because it is an estimate and there
there are um while it is not you know
specific and locked in stone there is
information that that that is available
that can guide like the example that I
gave you know the 5 cents per thousand
in the first year and then the 31 cents
I mean that's a huge huge jump and you
know PE the the voters did not have that
information and there is information
that that's available that can um serve
to
inform um what the tax impact may be
moving forward but to be clear when you
have a warrant at any annual meeting
you're voting on the information at that
time so that's what that that's what
you're voting on um like I said at that
annual meeting so so like I the
information that I'm asking that this
bill provide is you know future
information to to help to inform the
bigger picture and but again to
reiterate you're voting on the
information for that year and that is
known thank you uh representative gr
please thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um so I I I do
have a concern about the a similar thing
so the expense side the cost side of the
next 5 years can be estimated with
pretty pretty close to factual
information like on a bond we would know
it's an estimate still because the bond
we don't know the actual cost until the
bonds are actually sold after the voters
approve the bond anyway but we could at
least estimate those expenses better
than a tax rate which would include um
revenues changes in town valuations admr
those sorts unassigned fund balance that
may be returned to the taxpayer can
influence tax rates up and down
would you be opposed to an amending this
that would put the expense amount versus
the tax rate
amount thank you representative um for
your question so as as we know that um
when a bill is introduced it belongs to
the committee and I'm certainly open to
um discussions with regards to
amendments to make the bill more
satisfactory to to the committee and I
would also note that there's a bill um
that's going to be heard after this
which does have an amendment that um you
might want to take a a look
at um but then I I would also just
simply reiterate what I my response to
representative majority in that you know
the information that you're voting on on
the warrant at that time is for that
year and I feel that we do have
sufficient information and then in
subsequent
well depends on the item it would maybe
it would come become part of the
operating budget but again some
information representative
Murphy thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for taking my question why just special
Warren articles why not all Warren
articles because you have some towns
will have a water a sewer uh bill that
goes that goes under the warrant and
they don't have uh the impact statement
at all what the percentage of rate
increase over year over year they just
put down this is what we're looking
for and why not do the same thing with
all war articles why just pick pick
have thank you for the question um
representative I'm I I missed a detail
but I I'll give you might need to ask a
follow question so um a special warrant
article there are five types I'm not
sure if you're aware of that and so I
didn't memorize these yet but it is a
warrant article that's submitted by
petition or a warrant article that calls
for an appropriation of an amount to be
raised by the issuance of a bond or a
note it would also is a speci spe
special warrant article calls for an
appropriation to or FR from a separate
fund created pursuant to statute
including but not limited to a capital
reserve fund or under RSA 35 or a trust
fund and um also a special warrant
article is des is designated in the
warrant by the governing body as
special or as a non-aps or
non-transferable appropriation and then
finally a special warrant article calls
for an appropriation of an amount for a
capital project under stat statute so
I'm not I I missed the detail as to what
type of a warrant article you were um
specifying in your question and I I I
wonder if that would fall under what I
just
described a followup go ahead I have a a
warrant article here shall the town of
winest are raise an appropriate in
operating budget not to include
Appropriations by special warrant
articles x amount of dollars I'm just
curious whether that would be
have that type of wording that your for
this your uh 138 whether or not that
should be on there
also so the question is would would an
operating budget have that right this is
for you know be able to have an impact
statement on that you know what the
percentage of increase
us so in in the current statute as you
can see on on the bill it says any town
may vote to require that the annual
budget would then that would be the
articles so that okay so this excuse me
shall have a tax impact do you have
followup I I do but I don't know what
the question
[Music]
is yeah I'm I'm this is all a little
confusing okay we'll move on and give
you some time to think it over uh repr
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh isn't this
information available to the public
during the regular budget process I mean
I know I understand I'm trying to
understand the VA the real value of
putting it actually on the on the
article is that because you feel that
the uh whoever is voting doesn't pay
attention until they come to the polls
or what is the reason from adding this
in addition to the information as family
that's available to the the vter during
the regular budget process thank you for
the question representative so um for
those towns or school districts that um
this information is provided during any
budgeting process or at any annual
meeting uh you're very lucky that that's
fantastic I've lived in my town for 31
years and sadly over those decades the
amount of information that is uh
shared with the voters at any of these
um hearings public meetings annual
meetings is less and less every year so
this is a matter of transparency and
full disclosure and um
unfortunately we it's something that
that is not being done across the state
and it's important and it's it's a
simple it's a simple requirement so as I
said um governing bodies currently May
optionally provide this information and
if they do again fantastic that's great
th those um those towns or school
districts are very fortunate to to have
that um but also law provides that a
legislative body may vote to require ire
this type of um tax in Impact
information to be printed on the warrant
and
um I hope that answers your question yes
much representa Davis
please thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for taking my
question uh so you just stated that in
your town there's less and less
information every year and hence the
need for this this committee has
traditionally
avoided
supporting
bills that are the problem of one town
or a couple of
towns because they will end up being a
mandate Statewide in those in those
towns and cities that are not
transgressing in the way that you are
saying so can you can you tell me if you
have any specific data on how how many
towns and cities are not providing
sufficient information such as what
would be required in this Bill thank you
thank you representative for your
question and I I absolutely do agree
that making
or making laws for just one data point
is is not what we should be doing so I
gave that as an example because I live
you know that's my lived experience and
I shared that as an example as to why
this bill is needed I this is my third
term as a state rep and I Network and
interact with state representatives from
across the state and I constantly and
repeatedly have conversations where
people um complain about this very issue
and I did not keep a log of those um
Communications nor did did I ask um OS
research to to research this sort of
thing but to be clear um we already have
the this provision in law so it's not
something totally brand new it's simply
saying that
um
for towns or school districts that that
have voted to to do this to provide tax
impacts that the information shall not
the current law only has like for for
that year all I'm asking is if the tax
impact
is up to five years that that
information be
included so it's not um this is not
anything that's new this is adding on
and making more complete the
information that is already um enabled
thank you representative any other
questions seeing none thank you for
coming in appreciate it thank you our
next speaker will be uh Mr Brody desay
Association thank you Mr Vice chairman
and uh thank you to the committee for
letting me speak again today uh my name
is birie I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and um we are a
posos to House Bill 138 is currently
written um House Bill 138 mandates a
change in voter adopted estimated tax
impact notations on warn articles and
overrides the legislative bodies uh
previous votes um it requires that
special warrant articles with multi-year
tax impacts or lease agreements not the
tax impact for up to 5 years obviously
if the um if the agreement is shorter
than 5 years then it wouldn't list
longer than 5 years sorry it wouldn't
list longer than than the U the duration
of the agreement um estimated tax
impacts can't be always done accurately
for multiple years because of tax rate
changes due to updated assessed property
values and changes in unreserved fund
balances that will decrease the tax
rates some of you asked some questions
and kind of stole my testimony from me
um in asking those things but that's a
that really does impact your tax rat so
when you're trying to create a
multi-year 5-year um notation it doesn't
show an accuracy in what the tax rate
might be especially if you do an entire
reassessment of your um Community
additionally Bond rates can change over
a multi-year period which could increase
or decrease ESP warrant articles cost
per year so not only um do the rates
change even after you've approved the uh
bonded you know the the worn article to
go out for Bond um you may refinance um
and also the amount of years that you go
out to finance um that can also impact
the interest rates too um tax rate
impacts give an imperfect picture of a
warant articles to cost and only
consider the information collected
before the warrant article's approval so
without that additional context after
when the municipality goes out um
whether it's for a bond or when they
negotiate the lease you you know the
rate and the cost to the taxpayers can
change um you still may not know the
expense amount because you won't know
the terms of the bond like the interest
rate in the principal you know the
principal can change you can go out to
bond for up to the amount that the
voters approv but often times
municipalities they may get grants to
make decrease the the amount of the bond
um especially for a large infrastructure
pro project or they may find someone who
is a better bidder to do the project
um they also um leases are fixed so that
we can um you know we can agree that you
know a fixed lease if you do like a
10-year lease on let's say a piece of
Fire Equipment um that's going to be a
fixed cost that's not going to change so
in that in that respect at least you
know what the fixed cost is but again
after reassessments over that period and
you'd be mandated to at least two in
your municipality most do it more
frequently though um the tax rat's going
to change again on how much you're
paying for that lease um and we believe
that this is probably best as a local
option where the legislative body can
require this additional information so
the concept of legislative bodies
requiring the governing body to provide
multi-year tax impacts it's not
something we're opposed to it's about
ultimately it should be up to the
legislative body to decide so we believe
that this bill would be better done as
enabling legislation um and for the
voters to to deliberate and decide
whether or not to adopt this whether or
not this information is more accurate
helps them make a more informed choice
in the voting booth or a town meeting um
and with that I'll take any
questions any questions Mr
Des representative
stavis thank you and thanks for taking
my question this bill does say or
actually current law
states uh a town may vote
so how is it not already enabling if you
go to section two it says as amended by
section one of this act shall apply to
any town or District that has adopted
the requirement to include a no notation
stating the estimated tax impact of the
annual budget and special warant
articles and shall not require local
Amendment or read-option by the town or
District um right now it's only one year
this would mandate that every
municipality that does the estimated tax
impact for the first year that they have
to do it for 5 years we think that it
should be enabling legislation that if
you're going to require a longer
duration of the tax impact that the
legislative body should have to approve
it
follow go ahead representative so is
what you're saying that the legislative
body should have to approve it every
year not every year um it probably would
be done in the same way that it would be
done in the same probably in a very
similar fashion as to the current um so
the legislative body can currently
approve a warrant article that requires
the governing body to include on the
warrant the tax act um currently they
can only you know the legislative body
can only require the governing body to
do it for one year some municipalities
do do it for multi years um even though
the governing body isn't required by the
legislative body to do it this bill
would mandate that without going back to
the legislative body you'd have to
provide five years um without having to
go back to the legislative body and see
if that's actually something that the
do representative majority thank you Mr
Vice chair and thank you for taking my
question so if this bill were enabling
nhma might support but it doesn't change
the the concerns that you can't estimate
year 2 three four and five um accurately
is is that correct I would say that's
correct um you know there there wouldn't
be those tax rates especially as you get
farther away from from the first year
tax rate impact would you know depending
on the case and depending on what the
type of War article special warrant
article is would become possibly less
accurate um but again if it was enabling
legislation the legislative body wanted
to require this of governing bodies um
bill representative
gr thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question would the nhma have
an opinion if it clarified it was the
expense not the tax rate that was listed
um as it's currently written because of
the Mandate where the legislative body
isn't the one you know making the
ultimate decision of whether or not it
should be a multi-year you know Pro
expense provided on the warrant article
um we would we would stay opposed
ultimately it should be the legislative
body that determines whether or not they
want to require the governing body to
provide um any additional information or
information any other questions for Mr
Dees seeing none thank you for coming in
sir thank
please thank you committee members for
the record my name is Eric power I'm
from Brookline representing myself in
favor of this uh of this Bill HB 138
local um I think this is a really
important bill for
transparency um across the
state the you know the bill basically
lets people know when they're voting on
a multi-year expenditure how much it's
going to cost them in the second third
and Beyond years and having that tax
notation to give them an idea um there
are some towns in school districts that
do this volunt arily um but there are is
many that like to hide the information
and they resist it until the voters make
them do it and that's what this enabling
legislation does so that when the voters
when the voters pass this and I've
written two petition warn articles that
were passed on the first try to do this
in in a school district and in our town
people overwhelmingly says why wouldn't
we want to know how much things cost and
the subjects come up at the meeting why
can't we know how much it's going to
cost in the following years and I says
well that the legislature is not giving
us the ability to request that the only
thing that's been allowed is for the
first year so this would make that
available I would find it very difficult
to think that voters would say you know
I only want to know the first year and I
really don't care about out years I
don't think a voter is going to think
that I think the voters that Vote for
This want as much information as they
can on tax impact and I do agree um it's
an estimate it's an estimate for the
first year and it's an estimate for
outgoing years
um but you when you're making that
estimate you have to make the estimate
based on the current circumstances that
you have you have to just go with your
current property valuation and
assessment and the known best estimate
you have on bond rates if it's a bond or
lease rates if it's a lease and give
people an idea and it is an estimate
it's really a qualitative um estimate so
that people know if something's 5 cents
the first year and then it goes up to 31
cents per thousand the second year it is
a big difference will it be 28 cents
will it be 35 cents no one's going to go
back and figure that out but they want
to know the rough order of magnitude or
how much things are going to cost so
they can make a
decision uh if you have SP2 um official
balloting there are a number of Voters
that don't go to the deliberative
session and so the uh only information
they have is what's on the ballot and by
including uh the information with the
warant article it does go on the ballot
and help helps inform those voters uh
unfortunately not everybody's engaged as
most people are in this room um and but
people can use that information to make
decisions um I also served uh in 2020 we
were considering adopting an official
budget committee and we the uh the town
voted to have a what they call a bucom
study committee five-person committee I
was the chair of that and um as a part
of that we looked at peer towns and peer
school districts to Brook line across
the state there was 21 Pier towns and 20
school districts and so we looked at a
lot of the issues related to a budget
committee but a lot of it involved
looking at warrants and budgets and such
across these towns and and and about
half of them um when we were looking at
them they didn't have tax impacts so
people at least on their warrant they
didn't have it so we would have to have
gone maybe looking at a budget hearing
um to try to find that information but
just you know and going through it there
was it was it's definitely there are
some that are definitely doing but
there's almost an equal number that
aren't doing it for whatever reason I
don't know if they passed this enabling
legislation or if it was voluntary but I
just saw that as part of the study when
I was doing that I think it's important
that um this this is this is an
important bill to help make people
understand what they're what they're
signing up for with the best information
that you have it's an estimate and I
think it's it's uh it it goes to helping
taxpayers make an intelligent decision
on uh the commitment they're making um
especially with bonds you know we had a
warant article last year where the tax
impact was Zero which raised suspicion
well how can we have a impact of zero if
you're getting a bond well there's no
cost the first year because the payments
were all deferred that's kind of
suspicious the one that's even more
suspicious is the one that's very small
because the interest only payments and
that makes people think that you're not
spending a lot of money um and people
don't people don't translate you know
very well most people aren't Savvy
enough fiscally to know if I vote for
something for $300,000 what's it going
to do to my tax rate um but people do
understand if it's if I pass it's going
to cost me 25 cents per thousand on my
on my taxes they'll be able to figure
out wow I have a $600,000 house this is
going to cost me $150 and maybe I vote
for it maybe I don't so for those
reasons I recommend Passage and OTP on
House Bill 138 and I'll be happy to take
any
questions thank you Mr power
questions represent Davis thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so you just cited um a specific
number 25 C cents per thousand or
something like that and yet earlier in
your testimony you said you could only
estimate so which is it what should
voters
believe if there are such low
information as you
claim how how do public officials arrive
at this
estimate thank you for the question so
the estimate is based on the tax effort
that this warn article will create and
that gets divided over the valuation in
the town and that that's where they come
up with the estimate and it's up to the
governing body to approve that estimate
you know some estimates could be better
than others but at least it's something
than nothing and so people want to know
that and when you have a budget
committee they can actually do that
number and give it to the uh School
Board to the select board and um that's
accurate any of the further
questions seeing none thank you for
testifying
sir uh last speaker is Mr Joe
torelli I hope I pronounce your name
right sir
okay good morning committee and thank
you
for hearing these uh these bills I my
name is Joe trelli I live in Hampton uh
we've been here four years five almost
five years and I learned the warrant
article process after missing the first
one but the second one I tried to learn
everything and I've been pretty uh
vocal in Hampton at select board
meetings and at deliberative sessions
about
transparency Clarity and helping the
person that's walking
in on a Tuesday with 13
pages to go through with a basic number
of for instance 20 cents per th000 or 02
um 02 cents per
th000 I am in support of this bill I
feel that when we walk in and we see
these and it's an ongoing process to
have the first payment is going to be
this much and having at least some sort
of an idea of what we're getting into
before we get into
it it's going to help now last year of
course we had the revaluation that
affected everything and now we've got a
whole bunch of things that are coming up
this year
but I am in I absolutely in favor of
this because I think it provides a level
of clarity to the voter that may not be
the one that is walking in with a
calculator to figure out how much is
this going to cost them um when I see
the the tax impact statements which
you'll hear about in the next bill the
when you see that it's going to cost 24
cents for your budget next year it
doesn't say 24 cents more
per thousand it just says 24 cents so
that's another issue that I have but I
will um I I'm open to any questions that
you may have
and happy to
questions seeing none thank you
again okay that's the last uh individual
to testify on concerning HB 138 so if we
have nothing further I'll close the
138 rep report in the blue sheet we had
so at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill
284 requiring tax impact statements on
Municipal warrant
articles first up we have the prime
sponsor representative JD Bernardi who
is here to introduce the bill to us
thank you chairman and thank you
committee again for the record my name
is JD Bernardi uh Rockingham 36 Hampton
Falls Kensington Southampton Newton and
plastow um I'm here to introduce HB 284
which deals with I guess what your
favorite subject uh Municipal budgets uh
you should have three pieces of paper
associated with this one is the original
Bill one is an Amendment uh to that bill
and one is a revised uh financial
statement so let me start with the the
the the fiscal note uh the new fiscal
note basically says what OS put on the
original bill was wrong there is no
fiscal impact so that takes care of that
money issue
um turn to the bill itself uh we're
RSA
325 uh Roman 5 um B Roman 5A and the the
first uh the first part of the bill is
basically saying that uh when
municipalities uh evaluate whether
they're going to uh put this information
on the ballot it gives them the option
to do that this bill is about
transparency there should be no option
to put this information on we're asking
in this bill to require you to tell your
constituents your people that are
showing up that election uh what the
votes were of the various committees
that uh put forward the various warrant
articles or whatever is uh on the ballot
so this is a a a change from May to
shall make information
available the rest of of uh 284 is uh
Roman
5bb the amendment uh uh
H this
does a couple things that were on the
originally filed Bill and and adds uh
some additional uh uh
information first the cost of each
warrant article that is on the ballot
must be exp must be expressed so article
by article by article you have 13 Pages
or you have two pages or you have 17
pages each article has to have a
estimated cost made available to the
voter what's been added in the amendment
is the cost of fiveyear Appropriations
must also be ex expressed and again
these are these are estimates uh this
doesn't mean that you have to have it
exactly right but you have got to use a
good faith effort to express to the
voters what you expect those costs to be
uh and and uh if you're going through
evalu revaluation in your community
three years from now okay you know your
estimate may be a little off but but
you're using your best faith effort to
give the voter a real and true estimate
of what you expect those costs to be for
the next five years if you have a cost
item buying a new fir Tru or whatever
that you're uh you you're uh financing
five years or
more and the next uh uh addition in the
amendment deals with if you're in
multi-district towns you have to then
Express what those costs also are going
to be your proportion of
that the next part of the bill deals
with uh the total cost of all the
warrant articles that are on the ballot
so if you voted yes for all of them what
would that net cost of saying saying yes
to everything be and that must be
expressed as a as an estimated cost and
finally again uh if you're in multi- uh
District towns those costs must be
appropriately uh advised over that
fiveyear period so with that I will
committee thank you for that bill
introduction questions for the
representative representative majori is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
I'm so I'm going off the amendment in
line 14 and it says if this warrant
article passes there will be an
estimated tax impact and my question is
to testimony that we've heard on on
related bills if we say there will do
you anticipate that the public will
expect that that's what the tax rate
will be and the second part of that is
could you amend this to say the
estimated tax
impact will be instead does that make
some
sense I that's a semantical question I I
would have no problem if you wanted to
as a committee amend that say the
estimated cost would be um I I would I
if you're going to take the time to make
that amend mment then I would also
suggest you say the estimated increase
in your current tax would
be and and make it clear that it is
above and beyond what has been sort of
year representative majority I'm a
little confused so you're saying line 14
you wanted that word estimated to be
inserted no I
uh what I was asking is based on the
testimony that we've heard on on in
today um the word will that is in there
does does the sponsor I was asking if
the sponsor felt that the public might
expect that the word will Intimates that
whatever the number is that's what the
number will be and they won't assume and
they won't further read to estimate will
will
estimate I I think if I think it should
be omitted omitted I was just asking if
he thought it should be omitted thank
you for that clarification for me
further
questions
representative
Guth thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question I go to go back
to the previous question I had on a
previous
Bill why why are we holding uh public
hearings before the uh the warrant tic
or the articles are are acted on and
giving out to the town all the
information that you are wanting to be
put on the on the warrant article isn't
of should is there any reason why we
have to put this information on a
warrant article where it's available be
to the public prior to the uh acting on
that Warren article some other
place firstly I would say not everyone
shows up to your sb2 deliberative
sessions um often times people can't
spend the time to do that so this
information is a very succinct summary
it's essentially one sentence that gives
people Clarity of what the cost impact
of a specific article is this is not a
tremendous burden for any town to add to
their warrant article this is an issue
of
transparency uh I have I am a
represented from Five Towns and I
participate broadly in the Rockingham
County uh various committees this is an
issue that has come to me as a
transparency problem that many
individuals say we need more information
and you know I couldn't go to that
deliberative session I you know my
daughter has uh field hockey that night
or whatever it is you know I I couldn't
go uh but this information is going to
be very helpful to me a very simple
short oneline statement on each warrant
article one capping article at the end
it's very easy it's it it makes a clean
statement and IT addresses the concern
that you
have thank you thank you madam chair
further questions representative grund
is
recognized thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question um
previous to the previous article my my
concern about this and I I'm and I'll
get to my
question it's a it's an estimate right
when we when we estimate tax rate has to
estimate right so the prior War article
I had mentioned of potentially wanting
to amend it to talk about the cost
because the cost is a fact-based piece
that we can put in
there
um what is your thoughts on that piece
of putting the estimated cost for five
when you go five years out you have
estimated revenues estimated unassigned
fund balance some special Waring
articles use money raised from new taxes
one year they might raise taxes the next
year
it can when you go to estimate a tax
rate there's a lot of variables in there
so I'm curious as what your thoughts are
on all of
that uh
so cost is also a a you know a potential
uh operative Clause however I would say
that it's it you're suffering from
potentially some of the same problems
when when you have when you're if you're
estimating a cost uh the you know
warrant articles are being put together
in uh November through January to get
ready ready for deliberative session
sessions in uh in in in February um uh
you may not have all the bids you may
not have the the understanding of what
grants are going to be available you may
not have all the information so your net
cost is also subject to an estimate if
you will so um it's six of one half
dozen to the other this this uh proposal
basically
targets uh taking that cost which is an
estimate and and and uh converting it
into what it means for you as a as a
articles representative stavis did you
have a question
I did if you'll bear with me
representative it will be an ill-formed
question do you want um representative
frock to go first while you no okay no
um and I realized that the fiscal note
was
updated and that the fiscal note that we
received uh first is no longer valid but
I'm just
curious about the methodology in the
original fiscal note uh are there any
not following the precepts of this bill
would result in criminal charges I mean
I I don't understand why that was in the
original fiscal note well neither did I
which is why I asked Can you look at
revised further questions representative
fraus is recognized for a
question thank you madam chair thank you
representative um hopefully this will be
a simple question going back to the
original Bill line
three says um shall vote to
require is the intent of this
legislation to hold a vote which could
be voted up or down or is the intent to
require that the information be
published the uh the the entire purpose
of the bill is to ensure that the
information is published uh and when
when these various committees that are
coming up with their budget uh
information hold their votes uh I the
objective here is to say all right the
budget committee voted two to one in
favor of this so you know whether this
was a unanimous or uh or a majority or
whatever so you know how the various
committees making these assessments came
out and what that was what those votes
were and it is then
published followup yes um all right I
just need to to say one thing is that we
do have an amendment in front of us and
so the amendment um supersedes the bill
as filed so we should really be looking
at the amendment language and not refer
well I is the all right let me go ahead
I'm sorry I'm I'm thinking as I'm I'm
saying what I'm saying so I guess we
have two things to consider because the
amendment may not be accepted so we do
need to look at both parts I I apologize
um yes you may may ask a follow-up
question representative majority thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking another question in the in the
amended language on lines 18- 20 well
I'll speak bluntly but I don't mean to
be flip about
this why does Northampton care what the
impact is going to be to seab Brook and
you I'm trying to figure out why is that
important to have all of the towns
listed there and how can that
so Northampton SE okay so we're talking
about the SAU uh for wonet uh and in
your example okay that that would be the
example uh so uh Northampton looking at
all right what are we paying for winet
school uh versus Hampton versus Hampton
Falls versus seab Brook versus what is
um voters may be concerned that their uh
particular interests are are not in in
harmony or they're being uh potentially
hurt
or at a differential rate than what's
happening in the other community so it's
it's just good information to have to
see what you know how you are be being
treated with respect to everyone else
who is participating in paying for that
resource I might add that in in multi-
toown uh school
districts for example you know co-ops
the apportionment is different so when
the voters are voting on that warrant
article they need to have that
I'm just providing some clarifying
information
um representative grund is recognized
for a
question actually it's not a question
sorry it's I'll clarify with about
multi-district how it's done you you
sure you don't want to ask a
question I know it's more based on what
you guys were talking about than a
further
questions seeing none did you did I see
your hand go up out of the corner mine
no further questions seeing none thank
you thank you committee I urge you to
vote for this resolution for
trelli welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you again uh my name is
Joe trelli from Hampton New Hampshire
and I would like to uh amplify what
representative Bernardi was
saying about transparency and being able
to provide enough information for the
voters walking into for instance a
13-page ballot with a short amount of
time available to vote
um one of the things that I I have to
say is in my quest for this transparency
and getting warrant articles passed last
year for instance two to one
margin I had this in here shall the town
of Hampton provide taxpayers a more
relevant cost estimate for proposed
spending warrant articles this fiscal
impact modification simplifies awareness
of the expected cost for the taxpayer
associated with each spending article
and provides the calculation for not
only cost per thousand property
valuation but also
$400,000 valuation so this is not what
this bill is about but we passed that
two to one
margin because
we calculated with friends and neighbors
that 400's a great number because it's
easy to go to 600 it's easy to go to 800
it's easy to go to 200 for your
different house so in the draft this
year I went to the budget committee
meeting and in the draft of all the
warant
Articles the select board chose to
ignore the vote of the people and they
simplified it and it says the estimated
tax impact in 2025 is two
cents where's the rest of the sentence
two cents per what well you're supposed
to know that that's per
thousand excuse
me oh well we created a calculator for
you and we put it online so that you
could put it in and you can add your you
can put in your new revaluation into
that well that's not good so I mentioned
that at the public comment I reminded
the budget committee and all the select
board that were in in the
audience what was voted on last year and
passed and it was still ignored and we
walked into deliberative it was still
ignored so in advance of that I printed
up amendments to each of the spending
articles printed ready to go signed with
what the words should be we spent an
hour maybe an hour and a half on the
very first one for them to adopt what it
was that I suggest suggested the $11,000
is a great starting point I think a four
I think a $400,000 would be excellent
but I also would like to change the word
impact tax impact why isn't it tax
increase it should say tax increase and
I don't know if we can do amendments
with this body I'm I'm not sure but I
proposed reducing the proposed budget by
$2
million in our warant articles it's 24
cents it's only the budget's going to
cost 24 cents doesn't say 24 cents more
per thousand it just said 24 cents when
I presented my number of reducing by 2
million it actually showed a negative
number for the first time on the
projection screen at a w article at a
deliberative session it showed this
would
decrease your tax impact by 8 cents per
thousand
oh my gosh that's $32 for a $400,000
house so I vote and I I suggest that you
OTP this bill because it really gives
the people walking into the booth help
and being able to calculate it but can
you imagine seeing a negative number and
it'll say tax decrease or tax increase I
think tax impact is too generic and soft
thank you are there any questions for Mr
trelli
seeing none thank you okay thank
Dees good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you to
the committee for uh letting me speak my
name is birie Dees I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and um
we are opposed to House Bill 284 as it's
currently written um
House Bill 284 mandates that the legisl
well I have to speak to the bill as
introduced to the committee um none of
these amendments that have been
discussed today are public so apologies
if there are amendments that you're
currently reviewing and considering um
House Bill 284 as it was introduced
mandates that the legislative body votes
to require governing bodies to add their
numerically tallied recommendations with
each warant article so this would be a
mandate to the legislative body that
they shall vote to do this um it's an
unorthodox way of of mandating a uh
limitation on local control to mandate a
vote of the legislative body but um you
know that that's a concern of ours where
what if the legislative body doesn't
vote as um as instructed in the bill um
removes a language from RSA that permits
the governing body to if it wants
provide these tallies even if the
legislative body doesn't require these
numerically tallied recommendations to
accompany each warrant article which
then gets into the ambiguities of what
happens if the legislative body decides
that it's not going to vote um in
accordance with the state mandate um it
also mandates how the tax impact is
written utilizing the tax impact as a
dollar amount per thousand of assessed
property value um which is pretty
standard in most municipalities and
that's typically how they do it um the
mandated tax impact language is somewhat
confusing though because for example
what goes in the blank on um line 18 if
the following blank passes um I mean
assumption is it should say if the
following warrant article passes um you
know and we're unsure why you wouldn't
indicate that why you would give the
municipalities um you know what I mean
municipalities would probably be
confused what are we supposed to put
there other than Warren articles um I
think logically it proceeds you should
put waren articles but if there's some
kind of intent that some other language
should go there or options of language
um the legislature should be a little
bit more
explicit
um it also mandates this bill would
mandate a tax impact summary at the end
of the warrant article that reflects the
tax rate impact should every warrant
article pass um it allows the tax impact
summary to be approved by the governing
body which we you know we generally
support that at least having the
governing body have some um ability to
use its discretion to determine these
tax impacts with its administrators um
the only thing I'll point out is that um
you know voters will vote down warrant
articles and um so it might not reflect
the actual tax rate impact should
warrant articles fail I know in some
communities worn articles are often well
supported the ones that are presented by
the governing body but in some
municipalities that's not always the
case Warren articles are regularly um
defeated just because the voters don't
want to spend or they feel as if the
municipality can wait um to spend on a
specific item um nothing prevents
municipalities from doing a summary
statement um in the town warrant or
other public place for example um in the
town the municipality where I reside um
during the budget presentation not just
at the hearings for the budget but also
at deliberative um it's shown to us what
exactly the operating budget tax rate
impact will be and then the total impact
of all the warrant articles um and that
is often placed on uh communities
websites um you know voters often will
you know request that these things be
done and municipalities are flexible and
um support the transparency to let
voters know you know this this is how
it'll impact your taxes um not all tax
impacts create an increase in tax impact
um so the notations for example
oftentimes governing bodies will want to
include the tax rate impact to show that
a specific warn article won't have an
impact um in in in the uh in the
interest of creating Clarity and
transparency and ensuring that the
voters um understand that maybe the
specific warrant article um won't create
any additional cost in their tax bills
um so those are some of our our concerns
and um and some of our point points of
hopefully Clarity that that we'd like to
raise and provide and um I'll I'll
answer any questions should it be
Dees representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question would would have been
more appropriate to ask the sponsor and
I apologize but I'll ask you Mr the Shan
maybe you know you don't have the
amendment in front of you so I'll read
what it says between lines 22 and 25 if
the town has adopted use of the B well
I'll summarize um the total tax impact
summary shall also be included on the
official ballot before the first warrant
article
question is that
legal has do you know if that would pass
Dr
scrutiny if I so before the first
warrant article question before the
first warrant article question um to my
total tax excuse me the the my question
is what this says is the total tax
impact if all one warrant articles pass
shall be included as a statement before
the first warrant article questioned do
you know if that would pass Dr scrutiny
I'm not sure You' have to ask Dr what I
can share is that there's already
requirements in state law that bonded
articles and the operating budget are
the beginning of the warrant especially
uh in in traditional town meeting towns
and in sb2 they're the first um money
warrant articles and then you have to
have the um the zoning ordinance changes
presented by the plan board in an sb2
town so I guess an sb2 would be a
strange place to put it ahead of all of
the zoning ordinance changes and in
traditional town meeting it would go
before the bonded and the operating
budget which in state law are required
to be you know top of the warrant so I
guess it wouldn't be strange I just
wouldn't know how that language May
conflict with the existing legislative
language and I think that'd be a great
question for the committee to send a Dr
and to ask if they have recommended
language
further
questions seeing none thank you thank
power good morning and welcome to
government thank you Madame chair
committee members for the record uh my
name is Eric power from Brookline
representing myself and in favor of this
bill and the amendment
um in section one of the bill it talks
about requiring the uh the numeric tally
of votes uh in the Warren article and I
think that's a great thing um right now
it's sort of optional I guess the town
can vote to do that but if the town
doesn't vote to do that it's really at
the will of the governing body and if
they're at opposition to their finance
committee if it's advisory or a budget
committee they may just put their
recommendation on there and leave off
the budget committee or Finance
committee's recommendation that's
there's nothing stopping them from doing
that so this would prevent that it's
full disclosure on have how um how these
committees voted so I think that's a
really good uh update to the
rsas um I'd also mention that you know
the long budget process there is public
hearings required and then if you have
SP2 you have a deliberative session and
then a balloting session and a
traditional meeting you just have the
traditional meeting um the public
hearings are good they're hard to get to
I've been to some I miss some because
I'm traveling um but they don't always
talk about tax impact they talk about
numbers they talk about costs and they
don't always have the tax impact and
sometimes you have to get that later
when you actually see the ballot so the
best practice of showing tax impact
doesn't always happen but if you if this
bill was to become law you would
actually see it when you got to your
deliberative session or your traditional
meeting because you would see it in the
warrant ahead of the meeting um so I
think that's also really important and
also that you know each of the Articles
it's important that it's you see the
individual impact because um in a macro
view you might not know exactly what
your tax rate is but you know
individually voting for something
generally how much will it cost you to
go up or down it is still an estimate
because there could be revenues that
defay it but at least you have an upper
bound on what it would cost when you're
voting for it
uh I think it's a really good uh bill in
the amendment section two which talks
about requiring the tax impact to be on
uh the warrant and also on the ballot I
think that's really important to for
voters um they will they will um they
will find that information enlightening
when they're actually voting um and I
also mention on lines 18 to 20 of the
Amendments that
um in a multi- toown district not
everybody uses sb2 and so having it on
the warrant is important because that
you only have one warrant so if you're
at a Cooperative district with a
traditional meeting each Town wants to
know how much it's going to cost based
on the apportionment formula so I think
it's important there whether it's on the
ballot for in an sb2 multi- toown
District I still think it's valuable to
see how much is impacting your neighbors
who are in the co-op maybe you might not
like like how much less they're paying
than you maybe you're happy you're
paying less than someone else there's
nothing wrong with people knowing that
information it's not going to take up
that much room um but I think you know
for people to have the full disclosure
and being mandatory I think is a very
good thing across the state for voters
um because I think it will you know
people looking at a town warrant may
make a decision to even go to the
meeting um based on what they see on the
warrant and obviously in an sb2 town
when they're voting on the ballot they
will have that information right in
front of them so I think this is a
really good bill I think having the the
information in dollars per thousand is a
good one because I think that's a common
ground there's different ways that when
people do pass the tax impact how they
express it and prescribing it in this
uniform way I think is is a very common
good common denominator for for people
to understand and for those reasons I
hope that you pass uh House Bill 284
with Amendment and I'll take any
questions thank you questions for Mr
power seeing none thank you that was my
last pin card so at this time I will ask
is there anybody present who wishes to
speak to the bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do
so okay seeing none um we will report
out the blue
Sheet's doing
that doing the blue
sheet John you are are you doing the
blue
sheet I can do what
do okay on today's uh blue sheet HB 284
thank you and with that the public
hearing on House Bill 284 FN is now
closed
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 495 FN
requiring cities and towns to provide a
breakdown of tax changes in information
on bills sent to
Residents I do not see the prime sponsor
so I would ask representative Murphy if
you would be so kind as to
committee good morning Madam chair my
name is Dennis Murphy represent the town
of Winchester
requiring cities and towns to provide a
breakdown of tax changes in information
Residents and all the different taxes
that they that they
uh yeah thank you representative for
Arend good morning and welcome to
sit on there we go sorry uh my name is
Josh Aaron I work for Avatar Associates
uh we represent about or our software is
in used by about 160 municipalities
throughout the uh State I was asked to
be here by the uh representative from
The Tax Collectors Association just to
um I don't speak personally in favor or
against the bill as just seeking some
more clarification I guess um on some of
the language in the bill um particularly
I think that the concern was
the um this the statement in the bill
that uh the financial impact would be um
less than $10,000 I think um I guess
that depends somewhat on uh some of the
language in the bill and how it's
interpreted the um particularly the um
clause about the bill sh include excuse
me uh the bill shall also contain
include a notation stating the tax
calculation um if we're talking about
just including an amount there it's it
seems like the issue is comparing
previous years to the current year if
we're just talking about including an
amount like the millage from last year
versus this year that's a reasonably
straightforward uh change if by um
including the actual tax calculation
where we have to do out all the math um
I have sample tax bills here if anybody
wish to see them but it does become an
issue of space and some of that
information uh may not be available at
the time of printing the tax bill so it
would require significant software
changes uh that you know it's it most of
our towns we we uh Provide support under
annual contracts there are occasionally
things that are so significant that we
do have to invoice them separately it's
difficult to to know how uh significant
an impact that would be just based on
the language of um stating the tax
calculation is is what I see in the
draft um similarly the effective
year-over-year rate change it again has
to do with um how that needs to be
represented U on the tax bill if it's
just a you know we show it's your county
rate is a122 this year and last year it
was
the11 if that satisfies the requirement
that's reasonably straightforward if we
need to go in and calculate everybody's
nominal amount for this is what they
paid last year in a total County um you
know you paid
$27 and you paid $214 to the county that
becomes a more significant change and
obviously more expensive um I think
those are the two primary uh concerns I
I imagine they're um fairly easily
addressed um if we're just showing what
was the tax rate last year and what was
the tax rate this year on that millage
um and or even as a percentage increase
or decrease in theory um but but the
idea that the uh bill would show the
full calculation actually do the math
for people would represent a significant
change um I think that addresses our
main uh concerns and I'd be happy to
representative
Dolan thank you madam chair and uh thank
you for coming to
testify uh before us uh unfortunately um
the sponsor and the four co-sponsors
failed to show up which puts the
committee at a severe disadvantage of
understanding the bill understanding the
Genesis behind it and uh giving us an
ability to interact with and question uh
the bill so sure I'm very happy that
you're here uh and unfortunately the the
uh the uh the concern for for this bill
obviously it's not shared by the
co-sponsor what was was there a question
in there
or no okay well the question is do you
know how the sponsors or co-sponsors
feel about this bill since we can't
question them
I I don't sir I I I was uh forwarded an
email a couple days ago uh for a list
ser and asked uh if this would have any
significant impacts on software support
so that's that's right all I know thank
you um representative Walker yes thank
you madam chair uh you spoke to your
your uh software Avatar system y space
is limited on uh on bills that go out to
the public and I do know
vision and you got uh Patriot you got
Universe those are the older ones that
don't have any flexibility at all and
adding this would be a great deal
expense to the communities and sometimes
in
addition if some of these tax rates that
don't uh like for instance Rochester
last year we didn't get our tax bills
out till late
December so you're not going to have of
this so is that going to be a very a
problem with getting the tax B you know
with the information on the
tax I'm not sure the the timing of it
matters that the tax bills can't really
go out until the rates are set so at the
time the tax bills are printed we would
know those rates um whether it's you
know uh not till the end of December or
in November or whatever but the it's
it's the the space issue is just how
much information we need to put on there
again the concern would be that we have
to either um and it's also a calculation
issue that if we need to um follow
through the distinct amounts of
everybody's individual Bill the
components of the county the state the
local Ed all those all the way through
the system that require that at least in
our case would require some significant
changes in costs which we would then be
looking to pass on to municipalities as
well with the other older systems
presumably I I I can't speak for them
but I I would imagine they would have
similar concerns um sorry one other
thing that that your question reminded
me of
that the I mentioned about 160
municipalities use the software um some
significant portion of those actually
send a file that our system exports out
to a thirdparty printing service which
they can then stuff and print and get a
little cheaper postage rate stuff like
that so beyond the cost just to us and
our municipalities there would be some
add-on cost possibly they could be
nominal they could be expensive I don't
know for those thirdparty print mail
services that each town that sends those
out would have to revisit with them and
say now the bill that we've been
printing based on the information we
send you for the last 10 years we got to
go through and redo that process and
proof and and change those templates so
that could be a another cost that these
towns might experience if that makes
sense thank you thank you further
questions seeing none thank you thanks
time last pink card that I have um chair
thank you Madame chair and committee
members my name is Eric power I'm from
Brookline representing myself and I'm in
favor of House Bill
495 um I think this is a good bill there
may be a couple of things I wanted to
talk about with this bill um I think
having the breakdown is
important
um but I think I I'd suggest a couple of
things that you maybe you'd want to do
to provide transparency and if you feel
that this bill is too hard to put on the
tax bill one thing that could be done
alternatively is maybe make this
available on each Town's Municipal
website if you feel like you don't want
to put it on the bill because I think
that would also be a place where people
could do it and maybe they just get a
link on their bill to more details so
they could actually type it in and see
it that would be another way to do it if
it's going to be too much to actually
put it on the bill but I would um
recommend on the Bill where it talks
about
um talks it doesn't talk about Village
districts there it says the rate on line
four it says the rate for municipal I
would add comma Village District by each
district if you have more than one
Village District it would be nice to
know how much each would be um for local
education there are some some towns that
have multiple school districts and it's
always nice to know how much is going to
each so local education by School
District State education by School
District again if you have multiple
districts there's multiple U taxes going
for each
one um and then also the in the in the
numbers you know two three and five
below just say uh individually for each
School District or individually for each
Village District um I think it's
important because I know people like in
my town we have two school districts and
people want to know how much are we
spending for the Brookline School
District versus how much we spending for
our Co-op and it's not published on our
website it's not published on bill you
have to call the sa up and hopefully
they're they like you enough to actually
give you that information um and then
they can tell you what the breakdown is
between your two school districts for
both your local education taxes and your
State education taxes it's somebody
knows it it's just not being published
it's not out there and that's not very
helpful sometimes so I would recommend
either passing this bill uh with the
Amendments I talked about putting it on
the tax bill or taking this bill and
changing it into one where they have to
disclose this information uh publicly on
their website and maybe post it in a you
know public place I think that would go
a long way for people to understand um
where their taxes are going and how much
it's costing them especially by breaking
it down by individual Village districts
and individual uh school districts and
for that I I would recommend otpa on
House Bill 495 and I would take any
questions
questions representative
amendment are you asking the speaker or
me well yes you just said
otpa I would my you do not have an
amendment I'm just suggesting things
that you might want to consider when the
committee looks at it and things that I
thought were
things that could be uh make it better
representative stavis followup yes thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my followup but the prime sponsor is not
here so it would be inappropriate for us
to well we can't ask him if he would be
amendable to an amendment because he's
not
here thank you representative I believe
once the bill is in committee the
committee owns the bill and they can do
with what they feel they need to
and this being a snowy day on a vacation
week I think there's a little bit of an
extenuating circumstance but that's just
my perspective thank
you further
questions seeing none thank
sheet oh um no I'm
sorry I I I I received a pink card just
recently so the last pink that I have um
is from Mr Brody
Dees welcome back to Municipal and
County government it was in my hand I
just had in my head that was the last
speaker I apologize I think um I think
that's been the general operating today
um I nearly forgot to put in my pin card
though I thought I already did um my
name is Brody Des I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and um
we are opposed to House Bill 495 as it's
been currently introduced um so tax
bills go out quarterly or by annually
and the tax rate fluctuates throughout
the year based on the amount of Revenue
approved and and necessary to be raised
to meet the expenses and expenditures
and also the amount of unassigned fund
balance might be utilized to buy down
the tax rate depending on whether or not
municipality is allowed to carry over um
unassigned fund balance and I do want to
point out that the tax rate changes from
your first bill to your second Bill and
um and again impacted by uh by how much
of your unassigned fund balance may buy
down your tax rate um and this you don't
know this amount of money until you're
finished with your audit most
municipalities do their audit during the
summer months um this matters because it
shows kind of an imperfect uh picture of
how spending is increasing or decreasing
year-over-year looking at these
different rates at the different times
um it it doesn't it doesn't consider
also reassessments that will decrease
the tax rate and property taxpayers may
be led to believe that their tax bill
will be less um you know as much as many
of us in this room May understand how
assessments are done how the money is
raised how that impacts the rates how
the total spending impacts your rate how
reevaluations there's a requirement that
as your property values go up that the
rate needs proportionately decrease uh
many of our taxpayers are not as well
versed in um in the understanding of how
Dr sets the rates and how really it's
spending that impacts your overall tax
bill not always your tax
rate tax collectors and assessors would
also need to update their software to
abide by this mandate and we're
uncertain if the software providers can
make these updates um you just heard
from Avatar previously um it's uncertain
whether or not them or there are other
software providers would actually be
able to update their software in an
affordable way for municipalities to be
able to implement this mandate um
updating and changing the software also
cost municipalities um depending on the
size of municipality it could be pretty
expensive smaller ones it could be less
expensive um the bill is also kind of
unclear about where this information
would go on the tax bill um and tax
bills are already getting getting quite
busy and some municipalities also will
include other information in their uh
that they include when they send out the
tax bills as an increase of transparency
in in uh in the municipality um we think
adding you know more mandated
information especially information that
not may not paint the most perfect
picture of how people's tax bills are
going to be impacted um it might just
create more confusion additionally and
you know we appreciate hearing the the
previous testimony point out that um the
term Precinct is um that's not really
anywhere in our state statutes uh we
think it probably the intent was Village
District although as pointed out the
sponsors aren't here to clarify the
intent um and town it would probably be
better to be said Municipal because our
assumption is and again we can't clarify
the intent um because the sponsors
aren't here but Municipal would be
better because that would also include
cities um with that I'll take any
questions should the committee have any
and I appreciate you guys taking my
testimony thank you other any
questions I had one quick question I I
noticed that there's a fiscal note and
that the New Hampshire Municipal
Association was contacted by the LBA and
so they determined that the fiscal
impact would be less than
$10,000 that's per municipality and do
you have any more detailed information
that obviously that's an estimate I'll
double check but um I don't think we're
contacted for a um a fiscal note and
there's been a couple of bills where
that's happened where it's been
indicated we were or they used a tax
impact from a previous bill that was
similar and so we you know and at least
they've noted on some of those tax
impacts where it's been like similar
bills that it was a you know fiscal note
from us for maybe like 2021 for example
was one bill that I saw so I can follow
up and see if our person who does the
fiscal notes Marty Carlin he was with
the retirement system if he did but you
know I think when I last spoke to him
about this he was it was not of his
knowledge we were contacted and maybe we
were and went to spam or something and
so we can provide Clarity
okay so from NH I was more interested in
the 10,000
um that number it's saying that the
10,000 yeah I mean it's a pretty vague
fiscal note because it's not saying
who's going to be impacted by $10,000 um
my knowledge is there could
municipalities that would be impacted by
more than that um and I'm also unsure
why they're using the years 2025 through
2028 um I'm wondering if it's similar to
representative Bernard's Bill where this
is not the fiscal note that should be
accompanying this bill yeah those were
the things I was wondering about thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so at this time I will ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak on
this bill who has not not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
vice chairman will report out the blue
sheet on HB 495 we have one uh signature
in
support thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
FN so at this time um the committee will
take lunch and we will come back at 1:00
hearings
e
ready good afternoon at this time the
chair will open the public hearing on
House Bill
613 relative to enabling local political
subdivisions to vote and set a reduced
default budget option
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Harvey bolia to introduce
the bill to the committee good afternoon
and welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you very much Madam
chair it's great to be here um thanks
very much uh for hearing this um my name
is Juliet Harvey bolia and I'm represent
belnap District 3 um and I'm here to
introduce House Bill 613 relative to uh
setting reduced default budget
options um and this bill enables local
political subdivisions that have adopted
the official ballot referendum form of
meaning to adopt Provisions for an
annual choice for a reduced default
budget the reason for the bill is to
give uh towns more options as far as
control over their uh School budgets and
um uh
because that's been an issue uh
Statewide um and so we're looking at
this as one more uh sort of financial
tool in the toolkit for uh providing U
more control over
spending um and there'll be others uh
after me that um have a little more
information and can speak to the bill
probably a little bit better than I so
um with that I'm
I'm going to leave it at that you all
probably want to get home on the snowy
day so thank you representative are you
willing to take questions I can try to
yes are there questions for
representative Harvey
bolia representative grund is recognized
for a question thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question um so
in here the third option is you would
reduce the default budget by a
percentage so what happens if a default
budget that's reduced by a percentage
doesn't allow let's say a school
district to meet some
happens um yes I'm gonna leave that
question I'm GNA for um others behind me
that are kind of more aware of that sort
of the details pertaining to that
further
questions I'm gonna seeing none thank
you thank you next the chair
power good afternoon and welcome to
government thank you Madame chair and
welcome um thank you for the uh for the
opportunity to speak to you Municipal
and County government committee my name
is Eric power I am from the town of
Brookline representing myself in favor
of this bill I previously served as the
uh as a school board m in the Hollis
book line Cooperative school district
for three years and I've been active in
town
um um in town meetings and in school
district meetings I'm also the president
of the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire so this
bill is providing another option for
those towns and school districts that
have adopted the SP2 form of meeting to
um every year you have a operating
budget warrant article which has a
proposed budget and then a uh default
default budget and what's been happening
in a lot of towns and school districts
across the state is that those budgets
are almost the same it's almost
everything makes it in the default
budget and the difference between the
default budget and the operating budget
um is very small and sometimes even the
default budget might be larger um
because of the way the law works and I
know there's other bills coming up later
today to talk about the default budget
but this bill here um is enabling
legislation
that is adopted by a 3th vote of the
school district or the town whoever
whichever political subdivision wants it
and what what it does is it provides an
annual
choice for a reduced default budget
should the proposed budget fail so when
you adopt this legislation you choose a
percentage between one and 10% and you
adopt that percent so let's say you
picked 5%
and if the three- fifths of the voters
vote for that then you have this option
each year so each year you what what
goes on the SP SP2 ballot is the um
operating proposed operating budget as
one warn article in one
question um which is in the bill on
lines 8 to
11 and then you have a second one
immediately afterwards which says if the
uh if the proposed operating budget
fails you have an option to accept the
default budget if you vote Yes or if you
vote no then you get the default budget
reduced by the 5% the number that was
picked when it was adopted and each year
that's a question the voters can decide
for themselves on the ballot so from
year to year they'll have if they've
adopted it at 5% they would get that 5%
reduction option each year so
um the provision can be rescinded as
well if you do not like how it's working
for your town or School District you can
resend it with a 3- fths vote as well um
it could be put on the warrant by the
governing body or by
petition and there's some hearing
requirements that you normally have with
tax caps and other types of things and
there's statutory language for adopting
it to um answer the question about what
happens if the um if you've adopted this
and if you have defeated the proposed
budget and then you get to the default
budget and
somebody's that that fails and then you
get the say the example the reduced
default budget of
5% that will be the operating budget for
that year and now somebody's going to
maybe say well we can't meet our
commitments so meeting your commitments
I think you have to look at your town or
your school district and determine
what's really really needed and what you
absolutely can't go without um and in
that case if that gets to that point
where you really can't cut anything that
you don't think you can you can you can
petition Superior Court for a special
meeting to appropriate funds if it
really comes to that option um so that
would be the path if you can't live
within the reduced default budget that
the voters give you it's not any
different than smaller budgets today in
a traditional meeting um there was a in
a traditional meeting in cin there was a
a budget that was chopped by about
55% and they were going to have to live
with that they ended up holding a second
meeting with a more than 50% turnout and
Chang that outcome but if they hadn't
done that they may have had to go
petition for a uh special meeting in
order to uh get the money they needed
minimally and the court would decide but
that's how that would work but this
really uh what's the purpose here is to
allow the school districts in the towns
to provide themselves another option
when they have a tough year and they
can't afford more property taxes this
gives another option besides just
accepting the default budget they will
then have another option to get a
slightly lower budget and the most that
can be reduced by is 10% by the by the
by the way the language is right now so
with that I'll uh conclude my testimony
I recommend passage of HP 630 1 I hope
you recommend it a to pass and I'll take
questions seeing none thank you oh I'm
sorry I need to look left right and then
left again okay um the chair recognizes
representative grundt thank you madam
chair and thank you for my question so
my my previous question was about the if
you can't meet your legal obligations
and reason I bring that up is I am part
of a school district $21 million budget
we typically have2 $300,000 left at the
end of the year at
most I take off 5% off of our budget we
would now not be able to meet our legal
obligations that is my concern and I
would say if you look at many
schools they're trying to keep things as
Slim as possible um they're not trying
to
overextend and so my question question
goes to why would why would we do a
percentage when people have the
opportunity to show up at deliberative
sessions if you're in sb2 town to change
things at that point the making three is
that confusing to people thank you for
the question I don't think it's a
confusing um question I think it's it's
a I think it it will cause school
districts to have a more prudent budget
that that people can live with when
they're proposing it and when they're
negotiating it at a deliberative session
I think that in the case of uh a small
reduction you may have to cut some
amount of services it may mean you have
to reduce Staffing of some level you
might have to reduce a program but you
know there's a balancing act between you
know what the taxpayers can afford and
what the school district thinks it has
to do and what has to be offered so it's
it's a it's a tough call and it you know
there's a lot of opinions on that so
this is just another option for instead
of just accepting the default which also
seems to increase every year it gives
another path to getting to a more
prudent budget and it's something that
each district and town can decide for
and the last pin card that I have is Mr
Brody
Dees good afternoon and welcome back to
Municipal and County
government good afternoon thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you to the uh
committee for letting me speak my name
is Brody Dees I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and um
we are currently as it's drafted we are
613 get my notes here so House Bill 613
allows the adoption of an alternative
reduced budget um that only adjusts by a
percentage of spending rather than using
the current calculations the current
calculations and I won't read the whole
section but they're spelled out in RSA
40 col 13 uh ran 9 subsection B titled
default budget and explains the exact
calculation process for default budgets
um current law accounts for increased
contractual cost the municipality must
raise revenues for and pay this to make
sure that all their contractors the cbas
that they have to pay those employees
for all those contractual obligations
can be fulfilled um this is because
obviously in SP2 towns you can't stay um
for the entire town meeting until you
pass a budget and um and the voters
don't deliberate throughout the entire
time at the second session they go and
they vote and so if they vote down a
budget you need to make sure that there
is some workable budget for
municipalities or school districts to
have where they can fulfill all their
financial
obligations um we do want to flag that
the percentage that could be inserted um
if a municipality were to adopt this um
it could be very arbitrary and become a
significant impediment to promoting the
uh to effective and well-functioning
municipal government I mean if all of a
sudden you say well you know the default
budget um now is a reduction from the
previous year of 10% um it would be
extremely difficult for many
municipalities to continue operating and
to fulfill all their financial
obligations um you would see a cut in
Services you would see a decrease in how
effective they're able to serve their
constituents um and without this
limitation um you know that could have
um you know significant negative impacts
not just on the municipalities but on
the residents of those municipalities um
and this is also part of the reason why
the default calculations exist is to
ensure when voters are against increased
spending that the municipality can meet
its obligations and doesn't have to
necessarily cut Services significantly
um there is a calculation that um that
you know everyone kind of can gener
agree upon that is you know can be
workable for municipalities even if they
go into default budget for multiple
years while that might have a
compounding effect um our opinion would
be that this uh arbitrary percentage
would further um that uh that
compounding effect in a much more
dramatic way if municipalities were to
go into multiple default budgets um this
process could also become complicated
for voters because of the contingencies
that must happen I mean you have to vote
first against your budget and then you'd
have to vote to at least our knowledge
to support the red reduced default
budget so now you're kind of trying to
vote down two different budgets and our
opinion would be that that's a that's a
pretty steep learning curve for the
average voters I mean s SP2 itself for
many voters was a learning curve to add
a whole new way that we're going to be
calculating default budgets um you know
that that could be troubling
additionally I want to point out that in
RSA 40 colon
14-b um title default budget determined
by the budget committee this statute
already provides for an existing local
option for voters to allow the budget
committee to propose alternative uh
default budgets so there actually is a
process in state law where the governing
body can present a budget to the
legislative body and say hey we didn't
agree with the select board you know if
you have a statutory budget committee um
we think that the default budget should
actually be this this year and it's a
legislative body that ultimately would
uh would approve and allow for the
governing body to have that power um we
also want to point out that the adoption
threshold is also not in line with the
existing tax cap law it would move a lot
of these things to a super majority at
least in our reading um which is a
little bit concerning too so you know we
we think if a majority of the
legislative body decides it's going to
appropriate um you know money for for
specific purposes or approve a budget
that um that the majority should rule um
and with that I will take any questions
and I thank you for taking my testimony
this afternoon thank you are there any
questions representative majori is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question question uh Mr shanes
in your in your reading of the bill is
there anything that prevents this from
happening year-over-year
is there do you mean by voters
approving A reduced default budget and
alternative default budget correct no
there's nothing to prevent
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
and the vice chairman McDonald will
report the blue
sheet thank you if uh one signed up in
opposed thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
our next public hearing is schedule to
begin at
1:45 so that looks like we have about 20
wait
e
the time is now 1:45 p.m. and I the
chair will open the public hearing on
House
Bill 475 local relative to the
reductions from the default budget for
meetings at this time the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Dunn to introduce the
bill to the committee good afternoon and
welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair good
afternoon Madam chairman committee
members and guests I'm representative
Ron dun from lary I'm here today to
sponsor this bill that would change the
way we calculate the default budget here
in New
Hampshire a default budget in simple
terms is based on the previous year's
operating budget with adjustments for
default contracts and other
obligations theault budget has been the
topic of discussion in many towns for
years no one seems to like it but no one
seems to know a better way this bill
takes issue of using onfi employee
positions to fund other areas of the
budget that would eliminate this
practice when I first told fellow
Representatives fellow Town counselors
fellow Town staff and residents that I
was going to be submitting this bill
this legislative session they all
thought I was
crazy everyone wants changes but no one
knows where to
start um you'll get a lot of push back
um are you ready for this fight do you
want to open this can of
worms well here I am to fight this to
fix this broken budgeting system an
example of the issues this bill will fix
is using unfilled positions to fund
other areas of the budget departments
will not hire onfi positions so they can
use this money money to pay for other
areas of the budget that may be
underfunded or
overspent this practice needs to end if
the position is needed it should be
filled if it is not it should be
eliminated when the residents go to the
polls to vote they are voting on what
they believe is in the budget they are
not saying that department heads this
gives you a slush fund that allows you
categories this also allows the town to
spend on other the things that are not
in the
budget this practice can lead to
inefficiency and wasteful spending it
also leads to lack of trust and
transparency in
government the fixes on proposing
legislation will not solve all the
problems with the default budget system
but they are moves in the right
direction the default budget is
complicated needs to be fixed and
reworked this is one step in the right
direction to fix a broken budgeting
system thank you madam chairman for this
Committee in the time this afternoon
there are speakers behind me with much
more experience and knowledge than me on
the bu default budgeting system and I
would take any questions but I would
defer to them if there's anything
specific thank you representative dun
representative representative majori is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question um the uh police and
fire in my town are both um created by
Statute statute the number of positions
is created by Statute um like many other
towns it's hard to fill those positions
with this bill contemplate that the
unfilled positions that we created by
Statute then we could not default those
salaries for those
positions thank you for the
question that is my understanding yes
Farrell good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chairwoman I appreciate it my
name is John Ferrell I am a 15-year town
councelor from the town of londondary
and has sat as 10 years as the chairman
of the Town Council um to help me a
little bit with how I'm going to
structure my testimony would it be okay
if I asked the committee a
question no you could you could ask a
hypothetical question just to State it
but we can't answer that so I me thank
you so there is one member
representative Dolan sat on the council
with me for a number of years and
everything so I know he's very familiar
with developing default budgets what I'm
looking for is so that I can structure
my um presentation correctly is is our
number are there many other
Representatives who have actually
developed default budgets and I know you
don't want to answer me but I just want
to be able to set that as a premise um
Mr frell I would recommend that you
assume that that the answer is no I
appreciate that thank
you so ladies and gentlemen over a
period of years when we changed over to
a default budget what we have found is
is that the original writers of this I
believe looked at it and said that this
is a great idea and that it should be
some sort of a tax cap and that this
will control spending which which
happened is it's exactly the opposite so
what's happened is is that what we see
is that things that have become
Antiquated as far as spending let's
think about things like postage
telephone different things stationary
all these items stay the same over years
and years and years because the people
who are putting these default budgets
together are saying okay we're going to
continue carrying the same costs over
and over and over again so that we meet
the default line what's happening is is
that those items are all now what we
would say you know out of out of whack
or not in line so what's happening
throughout the budgets here in London
there and what we're seeing when we talk
to other people around the state is is
that we're leaving ourselves short from
the standpoint of having 68 sworn
officers we're only hiring 63 so we can
use that money to meet our bottom line
budget um what we're seeing is is that
as the medical costs have risen from
$23,000 for a family plan in 2010 to
$444,000 for a family plan today is
we're seeing that we're moving money
around for the wrong reasons what we're
looking to do is accomplish what I would
call S sp3 there really needs to be a
better form of budgeting there really
needs to be an entire overhaul in legis
of the legislation the legislation
intent was a good one but it has failed
now over time so what we're looking for
is that take that first initial step
here with you take that first step to
start saying let's start peeling back
you know the onion and saying what
pieces can we look at first since there
has not been an appetite for ter in
apart the entire bill so what we would
like to see from the standpoint of those
of us who support this is is let's get a
lot smarter about our money what's
happening across the state is is that
we're hearing costs are exponentially
going up everywhere what used to cost us
you know for a police officer at $60,000
is now
$150,000 for a police officer what we
need as an aging state is is we need to
be able to bring on more fire Personnel
more medical personnel so that we can
take care of the people who in our state
and see to it that they are cared for in
the right way yet we can't hire fast
enough to be able to meet those needs
because we're strung by these default
budgets the voters of course determine
whether we'll go over default or not we
can certainly present budgets that go
over default what we what personally
what i' really like to see is go back to
running this more like a business versus
working inside you know legislation that
is just Antiquated at this point I
something that was approved in 199 96 I
mean here we are folks 30 some odd years
later it's time to start updating this
start start bringing it up to what the
standards of today versus you know what
we saw in
1996 I thank
you thank you Mr frell are you willing
to take questions absolutely questions
Farrell representative
Dolan thank you madam chair and thank
you represent uh Council phoh for uh
being here could you describe for the
committee uh the relationship between
Department of Revenue and calculating
works so the Department of Revenue as
you all know sets the tax rate we don't
know what the tax rate is going to be
until we submit our budgets to the
Department of Revenue and we submit all
of our assessing data to the Department
of Revenue so um from the standpoint of
where we find out what we're actually to
have a rate for the for the um for the
actual homeowners or for the commercial
properties is unknown to us until we
until we do that piece was that what
for further questions representative
majori is recognized for a question
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
counselor for taking the question
um so similar to what I what I posed to
the sponsor uh the number of employees
for our fire and police department is
set by the ordinance that we created in
the town so we try to to fill that and I
heard you say that in your town your
lary is a town or a city it's a town
town thank you um you have
68 sworn police off 68 sworn but but
you're only able to staff 63 at this
point we're only Staffing 63 it's not
that we're not getting applicants we're
actually lucky we're getting applicants
and we're trying to get to 68 but what's
happening is is that we're running out
of money so um and we're because we're a
bottom line budget what's happening is
that money is being used for other
things that the police department needs
such as whether it be weapons ammunition
training training is a big issue around
all of the Departments you set a default
Budget on training and it never goes
up that's because it's it's just a piece
work thank you for the question did that
answer
seeing none thank you appreciate the
time thank
Christina good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you chairwoman power good afternoon
members of the committee barer Christina
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association we are opposed the house
bill
474 um in anticipation I I pulled up um
a website called ed jobs nh.com it's a
listing of positions open within a
school district they're over over 900
positions currently open in school
districts right now school districts
have staff turnover all the time PA
professionals School nurses bus drivers
teachers I could Le read some of the the
the job listings but to limit the
default budget to not include these
positions when school districts have
staff turn over all the time would be
would be impracticable the other aspect
that I'm not certain
um with the bill it says um position
line8 position turnover which occur
before the public hearing for the
proposed budget what is the start date
is the start date July 1 of the new
fiscal year for the school board I don't
or for the school district I don't think
that's necessarily clear um and I guess
my other question is what if the
position becomes vacant in the prior
fiscal year but yet is not the new hire
is not made until the new fiscal year so
for example somebody hands in their
letter of resignation effective June 1st
of Any Given school year and then they
don't get a chance to hire that person
until perhaps August um you know how
does that factor into into your default
budget they planning on filling the
position but it takes time to send send
out send out the advertisement get it
posted do interviewing hire people so on
and so forth so um again my simple
testimony is that you you know position
turnover which occurs before the public
hearing for the proposed budget is is is
not workable for school districts we
have people coming coming and going in
school districts all the time teachers
PA professionals bus drivers School
nurses I could go on and on but I I
won't so with that I'm happy to happy to
answer any question questions that the
committee may
have thank you questions I see
representative Dolan has a question
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
for uh testifying and and taking my
question not to nitpick but uh you you
mentioned that you're not in favor of
House Bill 474 you know this is
testimony for House Bill 475 475 my
apologies sir thank you for thank you
for clarifying thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Sean is
it Faber
faor good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
afternoon
um there we go all right good afternoon
um I'm also a town counselor in London
der as councelor fa frell well outlined
sb2 has its issues I'm happy to see that
this committee saw many reforms on
municipal government throughout today um
reading through the bills there was a
lot of great bills that came through um
I'm not going to go and repeat some of
the same things that he said but when it
comes down to it in the opposition to
this we have to go to what is the
definition of default so yes we can have
extenuating circumstances where someone
resigns right before the end of the year
or other things but we really are trying
get something where we are proposing a
true default sometimes going through the
budget process some of our constituents
are pretty angry with what goes into a
default budget because they feel it's
feel it's not a true default budget it's
not what it's meant to be so when we
look at this I would like to get it down
to what something is when we have open
positions and we hear frequently in
meetings how many open positions we have
how come they're still counted and this
would be something that would help us
address so we are being up and up and on
the honest and as a Dylan rule state we
can't do that ourselves we have to come
here and ask for help and um that's why
I'm here today to help speak up and get
something so we can provide better
da are you open to taking questions
questions for Mr
Faber representative majority has a
question do you just automatically look
right at me I
guess thank you madam chairwoman thank
you for taking my my question and I'm
sorry to keep harping on this I just
want to be clear that I understand the
perspective um and I'll use your town if
you have 63 positions uh 63 sworn
available but only 60 68 sworn available
but 63 filled are you suggesting that
you would not default the salaries of
the five open
positions so it would be something where
I think we need to be able to clearly
State how that works so I I think the
Simplicity of this bill would not do
that and I'm happy that it will be
something that's a little more
clearcut and we could have went through
multiple changes to reform default has
countless issues this is where something
where we're trying to take the first
step down that road to getting this
fixed it's a very complicated
questions no seeing none thank
you and the last pink card that I have
power good afternoon and welcome to
government thank you Madame chair and
members of the municipal and County
government committee for the record I'm
Eric power from Brookline representing
myself in favor of this
bill and um in our in our town we have
two school districts one of them is SP2
and I have spent a lot of uh done a lot
of research on default budgets and
looked at default budgets found mistakes
in default budgets that the school
district even uh agreed with me on
before it actually went to the ballot um
and there are some definite things that
need to be fixed and I thank you
representative Dunn for bringing this
forward uh I'm going to speak to the
amendment he he he handed out which is
uh
2025 d0 600h
and um first thing it does I think
that's important is that there's a
couple places where there's a missing
reference to RSA 40 colon
14-b that's the RSA that allows the
budget committee to get the uh to have
the authority to determine the default
budget um and so that was missing in a
couple of places and that's been added
in um I'd also like to mention the first
change that's on line eight of the
amendment where it says other
obligations previously incurred by law
or mandated by law and there's been some
situations where um people said
obligations have been previously
incurred and they didn't think the by
law applied to that because it says
mandated by law so this just adds it in
both places so it's really making sure
that the obligation is incurred by law
and not really by preference um so that
that's that's an important update um on
line nine of the amend been it talks
about um taking out salaries and
benefits positions that have been
eliminated in the proposed
budget um so obviously if the position's
been eliminated should be not in the
default budget the next starting at the
end of line nine and 10 it says by
salaries and benefits of positions that
were vacant before the previous year's
budget was approved and have remained
vacant so this addresses the the
positions that that are open and stay
open in depth itely and the money in
that is often used for other purposes
but it does allow for a year when it's
positions open for the first year that
it is allowed to be part of the default
budget but if it stays unfilled for more
than a year it goes out of the default
budget um and then on line 11 in the
middle reflecting the actual salary and
benefits of the fill positions as of the
public hearing of the proposed budget
that's important that was in the
original bill that means for example um
we had a librarian a senior librarian
that was making about $100,000 with pay
and benefits
retire and they hired a a younger person
that was getting paid with salary and
benefits about
$65,000 but by the way the law was
written that person was already on board
already working and that that that we
could not change the default budget to
$65,000 because of the way the law is
right now we had to keep the $100,000 so
there's already overpaying for something
we already know the we already know the
new person that's what this bill takes
care of and
um and then down on line 17 to 19 any
budget item in the operating budget
authorized for the previous year and
there and there was a transfer made for
a one-time expenditure you'll reduce
that line item by that transfer that
means um if you're taking a line item
that was and you start using it for
onetime expenses then that line item
will now be reduced so this closes sort
of there's I call it the uh there's a
there's a way to pad the budget by
having open staff vacancies that are in
the default budget but never filling
them or keeping them over for a long
long time there's the what I call this
line item harvesting transfer loophole
where money is put in one light item and
used for another for one onetime
expenses and then there's obviously the
other items I talked about in terms of
fixing some references and putting in
the by law um so if you have positions
that are vacant and they're vacant for
more than a year maybe with police or
fire and it's hard to fill them there is
a tool you don't pad the default budget
the default budget should be the basic
budget that you are passing it's the
Bare Bones budget but there is a tool
that's out there and we do use it in in
our our school districts it's called a
contingency fund contingency fund can is
a separate warn article RSA 31 colon 98-
a 31 colon 98- a that's a separate
contingency fund that can be put and
everybody knows when they're voting on
it this is a contingency that we want to
put $100,000 or
$300,000 and maybe it's for things that
wouldn't be in the default budget but we
might want to fill some positions and it
puts it transparently in front of the
voters so there's a tool there instead
of sort of padding the default budget
you can use this contingency fund as a
way to clearly state to voters that this
is this is the purpose of it instead of
you know hiding things in the default
budget the default budget is you know
I've talked to Dr myself they do not do
much uh enforcement of default budgets
they don't they don't really look at the
default budgets unfortunately that's
another issue but the number one
question they get every meeting season
around now is questions from you know
Selectmen school boards budget
committees citizens about default
budgets and so um there's this this this
I think would help that a lot because it
would make it very clear of these
loopholes and I think it would be very
good for Citizens and then if you can
use the contingency fund for those
things you think you need to have for
contingency that would make a lot of
sense so for that reason I would
recommend that the committee recommend
this uh H this house bill
475 ought to pass with Amendment and
with that I'll close and take any
questions thank you other questions for
the
speaker representative Dolan thank you
madam chair uh administrative question
for for the speaker or
for one of the prior
speakers the effect of date of this is
right now scheduled for January 1st 2026
does that make a difference to the to
what we should be doing is that the
correct effective date uh to get the
most bang for the buck for this
change thank you for the question
representative Dolan um I am not OS but
I my understanding is that bills such as
this would probably be in effect 60 days
after passage because you do have
some um political subdivisions that will
uh start doing things much earlier um I
don't think there's any s SP2 budget
hearings before January 1st but they get
pretty close to that date so yeah you
might want to look at uh checking that
effective date with OS to make sure it
makes sense there might be a reason I'm
not aware of that it needs to be that um
but that's that's my input on that
followup yes could I extend that
question to the sponsor answer or any of
the uh other speakers that are you okay
with January 1st 2026 or do you think
changed representative Dolan I we hear
that there's a question with regards to
the effective date and um we the
committee or or I can can look into that
and get an answer to that CU I'm not
sure that the prime sponsor has an
answer to that do you have an answer to
that okay I didn't think so so we can
certainly look into that and get an
answer okay further questions
representative
majori thank you madam chair I want to
thank you for taking another question
for me in the situation where you raised
where you had one salary at $100,000 and
then you had it you had the new position
at 65,000 or you know just using numbers
uh do you agree that the Delta would
fall to fund balance at the end of the
year or or it doesn't mean that that
$40,000 is padded but do we agree that
that money would not would organically
fall to fund balance thank you for the
question represented majority yes if you
have the money that's not expended it
would go to the um the unexpended fund
balance at the end of the year but
there's nothing stopping the school
board in this case with the school
district um from taking that
$35,000 and spending it on anything they
want and you know sometimes they do and
so the default budget is really supposed
to be the Bare Bones budget with no
extras and no padding and that's what
this bill tries to do and like I said if
you if you want to have a contingency
fund the right way to do it is through
RSA 3198 a that's the best way to do it
then everybody knows that that's a
contingency fund and if that's not spent
that returns to the taxpayers as well
thank
you representative grund is recognized
for a question thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question um so I
know we're talking a lot about headcount
but if we're looking at overall defa
default budget calculation excuse me
should we consider including
Transportation Utilities in default
budgets because Transportation by law
for k through eight is required and when
you have a new contract in a year it's
included in a budget but it's not the
default budget because it's last year's
cost and same with utilities that
constantly increase on us we have big
jumps should that be included in a
default budget calculation thank you for
the question representative grun my
understanding is that if you have a
continuing contract those escalating
costs are part of the default budget
today um so you know like a collective
bargain agreement that those costs are
already built in the default budget for
Better or For Worse followup yes so just
to clarify um so only if they're soriz
and nobody puts Transportation on a
special warrant article that lays out
the contract contct costs because if the
voters vote no then you can't you don't
have any cost for transportation so
they're always included in a budget so
no those increasing costs are not
included so that does again should it be
included in
a in a default budget
calculation the escalating costs should
be um in a default budget because
they're a contract if they're multi-year
contract but if you do not if you do not
get a contract approved by the voters
then has to be a year to year because
you haven't brought it forth the voters
the voters should be voting on that and
we do that in our district that we vote
on a five-year um bus contract and that
becomes part of the default budget for
you so at this time I I will add ask is
there anyone present who wishes to speak
on this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none Vice
chairman McDonald will report the blue
against thank you and with that the
public hearing on House Bill 475 local
our next hearing is scheduled to begin
at 2:30 so that gives us a little over
wait
e
on
HB 228 which is relative to petitioned
articles at an annual or special town
meeting and uh representative power if
you can introduce the bill
please thank you Mr chairman and
honorable committee members as the prime
sponsor I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today House Bill 228
local for your consideration for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
and Greenville and Hillsboro County
District
36 under current law registered voters
May petition the governing body to
include their petitioned warrant
articles on the warrant at an annual or
special meeting and this is provided for
under RSA 39 colon 3 as well as um RSA
197 colon 6 for school districts the
problem is that citizens are reporting
more frequently that their petitioned
warrant articles are not being handled
fairly nor with respect at town and
school district meetings as a result
discussion and debate of petitioned
Warrant articles is being severely
limited or it doesn't happen at all in
and in traditional meetings petition
warrant articles aren't even being voted
upon by the legisl ative body
unfortunately in many towns and school
districts petitioned warrant articles
are regarded as second class um warrant
articles by many governing bodies as
well as meeting and attendees and this
sentiment is evidenced by um comments in
uh open
meetings for example I recently learned
um of one instance where a school board
in fact was coordinating with the
moderator ahead of the annual meeting to
develop rules to
limit both the time and the opportunity
for petition warrant articles to be
presented at the annual meeting clearly
this is wrong and it's a clear abuse of
our system of
democracy to be clear annual and special
meetings belong to all
voters and not just the governing body
or certain groups of people so the
solution is House Bill 228 this
addresses these problems by first
identifying a primary petitioner as one
of the registered voters on the
application um for the petitioned
warrant
article or in the absence of an
identified primary petitioner the
primary petitioner shall be the first
petitioner our registered voter listed
application Additionally the bill also
allows that the primary petitioner May
designate any registered voter to act as
the primary petitioner by notifying the
moderator of such in writing for example
the primary petitioner might not be
available for the meeting and this
provision allows for another individual
to fulfill
that role the bill further addresses um
the problems that I outlined by
requiring that the moderator shall
provide the primary petitioner the
opportunity to introduce the petitioned
article at the
meeting and also the primary petitioner
shall also be guaranteed at least the
same amount of of time as the longest
time granted to the governing body or
the budget committee if there is one to
introduce any of their warrant articles
at the
meeting to conclude the simple change to
the current law levels the playing field
by giving both elected officials and
citizens fair and Equitable time and
opportunity to present all warrant
articles at an annual or special meeting
regardless of who places that article on
the warrant and also by allowing ing
that all warrant articles have the
opportunity to be debated discussed and
actually voted on thereby protecting and
preserving the Democratic meeting
process for all participants to me it's
a matter of fairness and for these
reasons I would urge this committee to
recommend House Bill 228 ought to pass
thank you Mr chairman that concludes my
bill introduction and I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you representative Powers uh any
questions from the
committee representative
chair you use the word may um line 21
for
example that
the application May identify these
registered voters
who who
determines that
this would occur than how is it adopted
thank you for the for the question
representative so what that's referring
to is that when you have a petitioned
warrant article there's an application
it's it's the petition and there's
certain um there's information that's
required on that and what was meant by
this with regards to identifying a
primary petitioner is that on that uh
application if you will the application
will identify this is the primary
petitioner so um I for those of you who
may or may not be familiar with petition
Warren articles often times several
copies are circulated and um so in terms
of the signature line and the
information that's
needed there's um multiple I guess I
would say line ones so therefore when
the petition is passed in the people who
signed the
petition a the that that whole um bundle
if you will can I just finish by this
yeah it will designate who the primary
petitioner is okay so you have a
followup
followup followup um I'm sorry I may not
have structured my question
properly who
enforces this
language how is it
enforced thank you for the question
representative if I understand your
question you're asking me who enforces
state
law well I guess so how is this enforced
or implemented within a
town uh this this if this bill were to
become law
it would um be implemented as any other
RSA is implemented within a town or a
school
district okay I'm
sorry it's okay I think that it has to
do with the process I'm not
understanding your question but there is
a process already in statute that
governs or pertains to petition Warr
articles very good thank
representative
majori thank you Mr Vice chairman so in
the exact same word why is that word may
there and not shall if in the next
sentence it shall be the first voter or
the the first the first registered
voter thank you for the question
representative so you're asking in line
21 why it says may identify correct
because that's an option so on the
written application for the petitioned
warrant article the petitioners can
designate this person on on this set of
signature sheets this is the the the
primary petitioner and in the absence of
that
then if
no if no primary petitioner is
identified the primary petitioner shall
be the first registered voter listed on
the application okay well that's a
little confusing I admit because I just
went and explain that we have multiple
sheets right so this I just explain this
multiple line ones um I have to think
about
that a followup
representative well sure and I and I
think we might be going to the same
place um are you trying to get to I
think you're trying to get to someone
must speak to this someone must be
permitted to speak to this article and
my question is does the
May shouldn't the may be a shall so that
we insist that someone whoever that
someone is speak to it thank you for the
question representative um that's what
I'm getting at I'm trying to provide the
provision that there
there that there shall be a primary
petitioner thank
you representative stavis
thank you Mr Vice chair thank you for
taking my question which is kind of a
rhetorical question but wouldn't
changing May to sha speak to
enforcement thank you for the question
unfortunately
I representative Elwood's question it
wasn't clear to me
so your question question seems to be
um
followup so if it says
shall then it shall and that's the
enforcement
okay I I I will I will think about that
um I I apologize that I'm not
um able to provide a sufficient answer
at this time I'd like to carefully um
think about it because
I I thought that I in my mind I had the
language clear in my mind but obviously
when other people see language they see
different things and I'm having trouble
seeing what you're all saying
okay representative
awood thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
representative power for taking my
question as an experienced
petitioner um of a zoning ordinance
Amendment
article I was indeed suppressed at the
public
hearing um to speaking to the ordinance
I was asked to withdraw it is that what
you're referring to when you say that
these art petitioned articles are not
respected thank you for the for the
question representative
Elward that that is is one example
that's a clear example of a petitioned
Warren article not getting um a fair
opportunity
um to be debated discussed and and and
heard and the legislature and its wisdom
has given through um RSA the opportunity
for citizens to be able to place
articles on the warrant through the
petitioned warrant article process and
not just to
um relegate that to the governing body
so that yes I would agree that would be
an
example thank you Mr chairman so would
you be amendable to an amendment to
change the words
shall thank you for the question
representative um I am open to
amendments and I am happy to work with
the committee to um arrive at language
that makes sense to everyone and not
just
me representative
Walker who is in charge of these
meetings I'm not a town meeting person
but who runs them
could you re I I missed one of the words
you said who's in charge of what who's
in charge of running these
meetings the individual in charge of
running meetings would be the moderator
the moderator because if you look at
page
two line 22 it says the moderator shall
provide primary petition identified
pursuance to
RSA opportunity to introduce petition
articles at the meeting primary petition
shall give given the same amount of time
equal and longest so answer everybody's
questions is right there there's a sh
and it says the moderator so the
questions chairman um where do you see
the
moderator where's that ag2 line 22
okay
so in my
example it was the planning board
chairman who held the public hearing on
the
petitioned zoning ordinance
language in either include a planning
board chairman
or because the moderator not was not
involved thank you representative I
appreciate that question if you look on
line 19 this is section four of the bill
and it says government of town meeting
and it
references specifically debate so this
section here pertains to the town
meeting and the town meeting process of
handling warrant articles you raised the
issue with regards to uh zoning
ordinance petition War an article
which requires a hearing and this bill
here
se yeah one last question
represent so I guess my question is
addresses public hearings by
zoning uh uh by planning boards
or thank you for the question
representative I would have to go back
and look at the rsas that pertain to to
hearings and I would need to understand
specifically in your instance what
exactly happened and what the provisions
are with regards to rsas with regards to
hearings to see if perhap what happened
was
um not consistent with RSA that what
you're describing is is like I said
something completely different has to do
meetings representative
Murphy thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question our planning board
amendable thank you for the question
representative I'm not sure how that
are the
what
followup go ahead we're talking about
Warren articles and I'm talking about a
article PL so the question is with
regards to and I think you probably know
the answer to this um but are your the
question is are planning B are warrant
articles
put up by the planning board
amendable planning board waren
articles pertain to zoning ordinances
and I do not believe that they are
amendable I could be wrong I don't know
but I'm happy to get the correct answer
questions seeing none thank you for
representative okay our next speaker is
good afternoon Mr Vice chair and
committee members for the record my name
is Eric power I'm from Brookline and I'm
in favor of this article and I'm
representing myself um I think this is
an important uh bill because I think it
it helps uh provide some civility to uh
annual me annual and special meetings
where there's petition warn articles
that have been proposed um increasingly
we're seeing and and I've heard
personally experienced it that um warn
articles at meetings are not even heard
they are tabled and you don't even get
to speak to them and I have coordinated
with moderators before and gotten some
time but it doesn't always work out um
because the meeting doesn't want to even
hear about the article so that's a
problem um I'd like to mention there was
a question about the sh versus May on
the um identifying a registered voter on
an
application uh I mean a primary
petitioner on an application and I would
say if you put the Sha in there then
that's another way for a uh governing
body to disqualify a um petition to say
well they didn't identify a primary
petitioner so do you want we have we
don't accept it so maybe leaving it as a
May would be good that we can talk about
that more um if you'd like um
but I'd like to mention you know putting
in a petition warn article is not a
trivial thing you have to get the
language right you have to go get 25
signatures at least from fellow citizens
and put it in well ahead of these
meetings some of the deadlines if you
have S SP2 are in early January some of
them are in late January if a
traditional meeting there are even some
and I did one this year that was due by
December 15th so these are not small
tasks and then to not even have them
heard is not really fair and people um
last year I had five at our town meeting
and four of them didn't even get a even
get to be talked about um mercifully one
of them they did talk about and people
said wow once I heard that I decided to
vote for it and they passed it it was
actually the tax impact one so you know
it's a little courtesy to give people
the chance to be heard and I'd like to
say that's kind of how the general court
Works everybody that files a bill and
some people don't like this but every
Bill gets a hearing like this every and
I know there was a there was actually
some rule proposed this year to actually
table bills out of committee before they
were heard and I'm glad that that was
stopped because every Bill gets a
hearing and every Bill gets a vote and
so I think this is along the same lines
but for our local
governance um I think they're you know
putting being able to identify a
petition warn article um having a
primary petitioner identified makes a
lot of sense um and then it gives that
that person is the spokesperson for that
petition and a lot of times they um the
governing body may have a question on a
petition or they want to notify somebody
that a hearing's been scheduled and if
they have that person identified as the
primary petitioner that makes it easier
otherwise they don't know who it is it's
not always the first person that signs
it and there's no particular status that
any petitioner has over another um in
terms of being a spokesperson so I think
that makes a lot of sense logistically
and I think it will it just goes a long
way to having the town meeting school
district meetings run more smoothly when
everybody can be heard and you know in
most cases you vote on them i' I'd like
to mention that under the sb2 form of
meeting one advantage of sb2 is that
actually every warrant article gets a
vote it goes from the deliberative
session onto the ballot there's no
option to stop it from even being voted
on the disadvantage of a town meeting is
that people could table an article and
you never you never even vote on it and
sometimes you don't even hear about it
so um that's a that's a that's a
challenge and that probably is another
problem to be fixed at another day but
at least for the petitioners to be heard
this is a very good bill um and
petitions come in different flavors and
I I heard a little bit about a
zoning uh a zoning amendment by petition
Warren article and as I mentioned
earlier I do serve on the Brookline
planning board so I'm very familiar with
zoning amend ments and it is true once a
zoning amendment is filed by petition
that's due very early as well I think
it's due even maybe there's a window it
has to be submitted and I think it's
between like mid November and mid
December because you have to have
hearings and such um and there are a few
other uh pieces of legislation with that
are official ballot questions that will
never make it to a deliberative session
because they go right on the ballot this
does not address those because they
don't go to the meeting but that could
be a subject of a an amendment or
potentially another uh part of uh
another bill at another time to address
these these more special type of
petition warrant articles those need to
be heard as well um no one should be
shut down that everybody deserves a
chance to be heard so um I think this is
a good bill I think it would go a long
way to help make things run more
smoothly when everybody has the
expectation set that you know this is
the way that petition Warren articles
would work they'll get respected and
everybody will be heard and that the
meeting will go more smoothly and
democracy will work better so for those
reasons I would recommend uh to pass on
questions I have a question for Mr poers
as this bill is written it won't app
apply to deliberative sessions in SP2
towns thank you for the question yes it
would apply to deliberative session at a
an sb2 town or School District
it doesn't have to be mentioned in the
right now it's just Town
meetings it doesn't say anything about
SP2 that I can find in inside in the
bill itself correct it does um it does
not apply just to SP2 deliberative
sessions it applies to traditional
meetings so it's not mentioned because
it applies to both okay when you have a
petition warn article under SP2 it's
heard at a deliberative session and it
debated and potentially amended at a
traditional meeting it's debated and
potentially voted upon there so it's
same place it's either going to be heard
at a deliberative session or heard at a
traditional meeting that's the purpose
of
this there's been occasions in my town
we'll have a petition War article and no
one will show up to talk to it to speak
or the if there's nobody there to speak
to it then the moderator gives the
opportunity and if no one steps forward
then you move on they had the
opportunity okay that's all thank you
any other questions represent rwood
thank you m Mr Vice chairman and thank
you for taking my question do you think
it's about time that we
start delineating between Town meetings
and deliberative sessions and use that
language in
bills so there's no
confusion because I I know that arriving
in New Hampshire I had no clue what was
going on and I found the
language confusing
um
and I think for the average
citizen they don't even know what a
deliberative session is and if we start
using that language in our um statutes
um would you be do you see any reason
why the word deliberative session would
not be used here in the um line
one thank you for the question I think
it's a question um the so there's you
have this is welcome to your world here
um because you have um you deal with
Municipal and County government
especially municipal government here
which is also school district and we
have annual meetings and that's a
generic term and under underneath annual
meeting we have SP2 and traditional
and there are some laws that apply to
both equally then there are some that
only apply to
SP2 which we've heard some today and
there's some that apply only to
traditional meetings but in some cases
there the law applies to both and you
have to know what once you get to when
you say annual meeting that could mean
deliberative session that could mean
traditional meeting just because the
annual meeting generic term means both
and fortunately I live in a town that
has both
systems and I'm familiar with both of
them and I've been to them and I
understand them deeply but I do know
that a lot of citizens don't they come
to me with questions and they don't know
how things work and um and there's even
state representatives that don't
understand that I think that when they
write a bill they only know SP2 and they
know nothing about a traditional meeting
so and I think you probably have seen
some of those bills in your committee
and I've read some of them so I think it
where it makes sense you definitely need
to delineate you know whether you have a
deliberative session whether it's SP2
whether it's uh an annual meeting or it
sort of applies generically and I think
in this case this one applies
generically so I don't think it needs to
be updated because it's it's it's just
modifying the three statutes right here
you know when you have a town and we
also have the dimension of town versus
school district and in for petition warn
articles for special and and um annual
meetings it's RSA
393 but for the wisdom of the general
court they broke out for school
districts it's RSA
1976 for annual meetings but they have a
separate RSA for special meetings for
petition War go 1972 so that's the way
it works it just have to that's the way
it is um so that's why this bill has
those three sections because the town is
covered by one the school district needs
to be covered by both cases so you have
a lot of different dimension it's a
multi-dimensional
problem any other
questions thank you for coming sir
justify okay our next speaker will be
Sarah Burke Cohen from the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association good afternoon my name is
Sarah bur Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the New
Hampshire Municipal Association opposes
this bill this bill is Impractical and
treats petition warrant articles
differently this dis this bill describes
the appointment of a primary petitioner
currently any petitioner may speak to
the petitioned warrant article does not
seem necessary to have legislation to
appoint a primary petitioner when this
seems to happen organically during the
petitioned warrant article process and
application
process this requires the moderator to
allow the primary petitioner to
introduce their petitioned warrant
article at the meeting introduce is a
vague and undefined term in the bill
that would create confusion is it a
presentation is it merely reading the
article is it something
else page 2 lines 24 through3 read the
primary petitioner shall be given the
same amount of time equal to the longest
amount of time granted to the governing
body or budget committee to introduce
any War warrant article at the meeting
this language would require moderators
to pull out their stopwatch for every
presentation by the governing body or
budget committee tally the time and then
determine the longest amount of the of
time granted to the governing body or
committee which would obviously change
throughout the meeting and then grant
that to this primary uh to the primary
um petitioner of the petitioned warrant
article it puts petition warrant
articles in a separate category than any
other warrant article and doesn't
consider that some warrant articles like
the budget or Lodge bond issue Bond
project bonded project may need to be
may need a more extended presentation
that voters want to hear so they can
make an informed decision about the
complex issues in essence this means all
PCI petitioned warrant articles would be
required to have the longest amount of
time granted to the governing body or
budget committee if this time is an hour
then each primary petitioner on a
petitioned warrant article would have
one hour to introduce
their article if there are five
petitioned warrant articles this could
be five hours what if there are more
than five petition warrant articles at
the meeting this could add significant
time onto annual or or special meetings
it could allow one person to hold the
entire legislative body captive during
an introduction essentially it could
allow one person to fill a buster at the
town meeting the legislative um what
does this bill mean in terms of the
ability of the legislative body it
should be the legislative body that Li
sets limits on how long people speak or
ask questions and be able to vote to
facilitate voter votes on warrant
articles this bill would give one person
the ability to hold captive the
legislative body to hear information
that they may not find necessary to to
hear or vote to to to vote on the
petition warrant
article in addition as the legislative
body can set limits on how long people
can speak the legislative body can also
overrule the moderator and allow the
petitioner to speak longer if the
legislative body finds it necessary or
needed Additionally the legislative body
cannot table petition Warren articles if
they want to proceed and and hear
them the bill this bill seemingly takes
that power away from the legislative
body and instead grants it to this
primary petitioner of uh a petitioned
warrant article nhma opposes this bill
and urges you to do likewise I will I'm
open for
questions any questions from the
committee representative award thank you
Mr Vice chair thank you for taking my
question um out of curiosity how what is
the process for the legislative body
setting limits on on the time the people
can speak how does the legislative body
do that well the legislative body so the
moderator is the facilitator of the
meeting the legislative body certainly
can set limits on on debate by calling
the question or as I as I understand
setting limits further on in the meeting
so if the meeting goes on for a while
setting limits on the debate amount of
debate follow up
sir yes go ahead so someone in the
legislative body can make a motion to
set a limit on the time that speakers
can speak correct correct okay thank you
any other
trelli sorry Joe terrelli from Hampton
New Hampshire
um I rise in favor of this bill I have
been subject to a couple of
interesting events at the deliberative
session uh one of the first things that
I uh wanted to mention representative
award said the town meeting versus Del
liberative session versus the election
these are all very confusing to people
that are just arriving and it took me a
year to understand how amazingly
important the deliberative session is
but I now when I first take the floor
microphone I welcome everyone to the
town marketing event this is where the
town has chosen where the town wants to
spend the money and they get to do all
of their presentations with slides and
with all kinds of PowerPoint and
pictures some do it better than others I
complained the first year and then they
finally got their act together and
started doing a little bit better job I
worked at Apple for a long time so I
kind of have idea about
marketing why wouldn't a petition Ward
article sponsor want to be able to do a
presentation on the screen something
visual something that's very clear
something that's understandable so I
like this a lot I think it's a really
great idea I think we should call it the
town marketing event because they're
asking for lots and lots and lots of
money for this and for that and here's
the default versus here's the the other
versus the proposed so I'm in favor of
this thank
you thank you Mr Terell any questions
from the
committee representative
Frank thank you Mr Vice chair thank you
for taking my
question uh is there anything that would
prohibit a Town's person from putting
together a PowerPoint deck and showing
slides with his his introduction his or
her
introduction that's a great question I
appreciate it because when I spoke to
the moderator two years ago when I was
creating on my iPad the value of the
$400,000 after every one of the spending
articles so that I could hold it up in
front of the camera it's absolutely a
great idea to do a PowerPoint but I
really recommend that there be some sort
of a the moderator needs to review what
the presentation is ahead of time
because you don't know what's going to
end up being there and that's I don't
have a problem with that whatsoever it's
kind of like staging an event somebody
needs to clarify it and make sure that
it's okay and the moderator being in
charge of the marketing event I wouldn't
have a problem with that at all
followup yes follow up um my question
was is there anything that would
prohibit that to your knowledge to my
knowledge no it's just it could be even
a range
in the background but I think if it was
available by law that would be a really
great thing to enhance this and I think
we need to get as many people out to
deliberative session or marketing event
as possible because it is the mechanism
and it took I'm sorry I missed the first
year but oh my gosh this is the single
most important mechanism for we as the
people to be able to help understand and
after the revaluation
everybody started paying more attention
all of a sudden and so there's a lot of
people that have gathered together that
are now friendly and discussing things
on how can we effectively make our lives
a little easier instead of more
difficult thank
you any other further
questions I seeing none thank you for
coming in sir thank you very much that
was our last speaker is there anyone in
the audience that wants to uh speak con
turning HB
228 okay seeing then now close to public
hearing on the blue sheet we have uh
it
for
e
okay it's uh 3:10 p.m. and I'll open the
public hearing on HB 168 which is
relative to including Municipal Public
Work facilities as eligible Capital
facilities for the assessment of impact
fees and presenting the bill is a
representative
power thank you Mr chairman and
honorable committee members you will be
happy to know that this is the last bill
that I will be introducing today as a
prime sponsor I appreciate the
opportunity to introduce to you today
House Bill 168 for your consideration
for the record I am representative Diane
power I represent the towns of Brookline
Mason in Greenville in Hillsboro County
District
36 under current law municipalities
through its planning boards May assess
impact fees on new development or
construction that is driving the need
for a new or expanded Municipal
facilities impact fees enable
municipalities to help to be able ble to
recover some of the costs for these
Municipal facilities necessitated by the
growth due to the um construction or
development so this provision is under
RSA 674 colon 21 Roman numeral 5 a
through L and it falls under Innovative
land use controls and they prescribe
methods for computing the impact fees
and planning board also work with
regional planning commissions to ensure
compliance with regards to the impact
fee um calculations impact fees are
collected to help share the cost of
Municipal facilities with both current
and new property owners and it's
amortized over the life of the
facilities currently there are 21
eligible Capital facility purposes spe
ified in RSA for which an impact fee may
be assessed and this includes such
things as public water and sewer storm
water public roads municipal offices
Public Schools public safety Solid Waste
public libraries and
Recreation however the list does not in
currently include Public Works
facilities which appears to be an
oversight so the solution is a spill
before you House Bill 168 corrects this
oversight by simply adding Public Works
facilities to the current list of
eligible Capital facilities for the
assessment of impact fees in the past 5
years there are at um at least five
municipalities that I've been able to
identify that have constructed new
Public Works facilities but they
unfortunately cannot collect impact fees
because it's not included in the list um
these municipalities include nashaa
Hollis Brookline Rochester and Groton
and additionally uh sixth municipality
was recently identified and that was
Guilford they have a um $1.2 million
bond for a new Public Works facility on
their March 11th ballot which will be
held in a couple of weeks the addition
of Public Works facilities to the
current list of eligible Capital
facilities is both fair and reasonable
therefore I urge this committee to
recommend ought to pass on House Bill
168 that concludes my bill introduction
and I'm happy to answer any
committee I just have one uh quick run
representative yep what's the basic
different so um the definition is in
statute and it says impact fee means a
fee or assessment imposed upon
development including
subdivision building construction or
other land use change in order to help
meet the needs occasioned by that
development for the construction or
Improvement of capital facilities owned
or operated by it's it's in the statute
already I I don't I don't really need
probably need to continue to read that
unless you want me to no that's fine I
was just trying to get a general
definition how would it work on a public
works facility does the town say you ow
us who pays for that or whatever I guess
so if I understand your question we
already have impact fees and we already
have 21 purposes for which impact fees
may be assessed and so clearly Public
Works facilities you know or commonly
known as DPW facilities that's the
municipal um facility that that I'm
referencing with regards to this
particular bill it seems to be in an
obvious um
Municipal uh purpose or facility within
a town and it's not on the list for some
reason as a list has evolved over time I
hope that answers your
question so in the budget they would
have a certain amount of money paid to
the town from the taxpayers we the only
time if I can just say we use impact
fees if there's a Development coming in
then they pay a certain amount of money
for each lot to develop it I I don't
think we've ever used this on any any
owns again if I understand your question
what I'm hearing is that in your
particular um municipality you don't
assess impact fees it's it's optional
it your planning board can go and and
look into it and it's a it's a zoning
ordinance is my understanding in order
to be able to assess it okay thank you
uh any other
questions thank you representative thank
you okay that was the last uh Pink Cod
we have on this bill HB 168 does anyone
power thank you Mr Vice chair um I think
I did put a pink card in but that's okay
um for the record my name is Eric power
I'm from Brookline representing myself
and also in favor of HB 168 as I
mentioned previously I've been serving
on the planning board since
2021 and impact fees are proposed by the
planning board in each Town um the
planning board proposes them and they're
adopted like any other zoning Amendment
um they go through the public hearing
process and then they go on the official
ballot on Election Day for adoption by
voters so the impact fees or the basic
idea of an impact fee is to help with
new house
new commercial properties subdivisions
to share a little bit of the cost of the
municiple facilities that are being
driven by the growth of the town and
that's why they have these purposes
listed here and you have to keep in mind
um there's a lot of subparagraphs that
that prescribe how impact fees have to
be calculated it's fairly complex I
understand it pretty well but the
regional planning commissions help us to
make sure we're following that the the
amateurz and everything of the fees but
what it boils down to is a fee gets um
when you have a new house they're going
to they're going to have a small fee in
the few hundred range um based on any of
the facilities that are being expanded
or a new facilities that are based on
the growth in the town it also helps the
taxpayers not have to shoulder the
burden of all the burden of the new
facility and it's shared equitably and
there's a whole formula for how that
works the problem we have is that this
law says um it says the list is
including and limited to so it has to be
on the list in order for you to collect
an impact
fee and um you know we had built a new
Public Works facilities in Brookline in
2022 but we cannot collect impact fees
on public work facilities because it's
missing in the law and as mentioned
earlier our neighbors in Hollis had
built one recent Rec l in Nashua
Rochester has done one Groton has done
one and Guilford looks like they're
going to do one so there's at least six
municipalities that we're that I'm aware
of that may have be be able to do the
impact fees it's not mandatory this just
gives the planning board and ultimately
the voters of the town the decision if
they want to um charge an impact fee for
uh under this Innovative land use
controls so I think it's it's a logical
addition I think I don't know why it was
missing but the three words that are
being added to this bill is probably one
of the shortest Bills ever but uh for
those reasons I would recommend passage
of this bill to help enable um the
impact fees to be more effective in uh
New Hampshire thank
you thank you Mr power I appreciate that
explanation I've got a better
understanding of uh of the law now any
questions
seeing none thank you sir thank
you that's the last pink C that I have
anyone else want to testify seeing
none um on this bill we have three in
favor and I'll close the public hearing
e
the clock has just struck 3:30 p.m. so
at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 124 enabling a
city or town Forest committee to offer
Surplus money
to the town for deposit in the city or
fund at this time the chair recognizes
representative Davis to introduce the
bill to our committee good afternoon and
welcome to Municipal and County
government good afternoon and thank you
madam chair members of the committee I
apologize for any confusion there's a
couple of amendments here I believe the
content is the same the one I just
passed out
uh puts me back at Prime sponsor and and
so it I believe it's the two that you
have in front of you are identical other
than
that um so I'm here to to introduce
House Bill
124 it pertains to uh Municipal and Town
and County forest a community Forest so
so I put this bill in because a member
from the town forest for the town of
arel came to me and in the the RSA right
now there there's
uh there's they they Timber they do
timber harvesting on the this these
Parcels they have 8,500 acres in their
Town Forest and they generate quite a
bit of Revenue each year so according to
Dr the three things they can spend that
money on they can buy more land they can
maintain their land or they can buy
something for the town uh through the
select board if it's a benefit to their
land so one year they bought a fire
truck for the town of arrel and and what
that the town of arel figured or Dr
figured that if there was a fire that
may save the the community Forest so the
the intent
originally was once they acquired the
amount of land that they wanted their
goal was 8,500 acres and it's pretty
well maintained they harvest they do a
harvest each year
so they're at a point now where they
wanted to use any surplus for for tax
relief for the Town members and Dr
doesn't allow it the way the RSA is
written it's not clear enough uh so what
this this does is bring a little bit of
clarity so Dr would allow them if they
so there's a board of three to five
people on the on any town or Community
Forest so it this doesn't mandate
anything it gives them the opportunity
if they deem they have a surplus they
can offer that Surplus to the select
board to put it through a warrant
article so that the town could vote to
accept that money without this bill a
town like arrol could be sitting on
millions of dollars that is kind of
landlock they just can't use it um so
the the idea would be so that they could
lower their their tax base um I live in
the town of milin we have a a town for
us as well it's not as big as theirs our
goal is 5,000 Acres we're at 3500 the
way our ours was set up we can do this
it's just it was set up properly from
the beginning but towns like arrel and
other towns that did not know how to
properly set this up have a have a a
block in their system right now so this
would correct
that and I mean that's that's a pretty
simple bill this is all it does I'd be
questions thank you representative Davis
other questions representative stavis is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question if other towns are able to do
this why
isn't why is this needed well it it all
depends how you set up your town forest
in the first place the the members that
set up the one in
mil for a lack of better words they knew
how to how to do it and they they set it
up so they could use it in general funds
if they had a surplus the one in arrrow
wasn't set up like that so this would be
a way for them to catch up with the
other
towns yes followup thank you madam
chair but if it's the state that
determines what the towns can do I'm
still not not understanding why towns
cannot do it if some are already doing
it the the way Dr interprets the RSA I
was told that they they cannot do it
amendment I I don't I I hope I answered
your question I don't know the it does
sound unfair but it the way it was set
up in mil they put that provision in
further questions representative frock
is recognized for a question thank you
madam chair uh representative Davis
thank you for appearing and for uh
presenting this bill I have a question
on the last sentence which says the
legislative body of the
municipality shall vote to accept the
Surplus for deposit in my mind voting
implies a choice but the way this is
written you shall vote to accept there's
no choice and perhaps some better
language could be worked
out that's a good question possibly uh
this whole Amendment it says not
withstanding RSA 31 semicolon 95- B if
the forestry committee or conservation
committee which is the group that has
control over the forestry committee
determines there is
a that the special Forest maintenance
fund has a surplus that committee may
offer this Surplus to the municipality
which I believe is the select board for
depositing the unreserved fund balance
the legislative body which would be the
town people if this came as under a
warrant
article I guess shall shall vote to
accept this deposit I I can't imagine
somebody turning it down so that
property taxes would would be alleviated
but they have the option they they shall
vote Yes or No whether they want to
accept that
money
followup yes followup wouldn't it be
just simpler to say that if the
conservation committee or the forestry
committee determines that there's a
surplus it shall be deposited in the
town's general fund well I I thought
this
would give more control so that like the
select board just doesn't spend it
frivolously on whatever they want the
towns people could have would have to
control one more
followup yes you may have one more
followup thank you madam
chair
so once the funds are accepted into the
general
fund then it could be spent however uh
I'm not sure I understand
why what what the advantage is or where
where the town's people would gain
control of this money so that it could
be used for a specific
purpose which is what I heard you say in
question I don't really have a good
answer for you I'm sorry
representative grund is recognized for a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question yes is it
possible that a the Lo the local
legislative body can just change this on
their own versus having to make it a
state
RSA the uh the the member of the
aeral um Community Forest came to me
asking he said that they wanted to know
if we could put this in and I
I don't know if they have the ability to
change that on their own I do not know
that
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so that's the one and only pink card
that I have so I will ask at this time
is there anyone present who wishes to
speak to this bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do
so seeing none the vice chairman will
sheet chairman power we have uh five
Bill thank you and with that the chair
will close the public hearing on House
our next public hearing is scheduled to
begin at 3:45 it is now 3:39 according
to my clock so we have now it just
minutes
e
time I would like to ask if you're here
to um testify on House Bill 50 one
please submit your PIN cards cuz I'm
trying to figure out um how many people
wish to speak and we have an hour and 15
minutes um left in the day so I need to
could the prime sponsor fill out a pink
card when the prime
chance
good afternoon before I open up the
hearing on the last bill publicly
noticed for municipal and County
government I do have a quite a few pink
cards so in order to be able to fit uh
everybody in here today by 5 p.m. I'm
going to need to um impose a 5 minute
limit for for
Testimony Then followed by questions and
answers uh the vice chair will indicate
he will have to keep track of the time
and he will indicate that you are um
nearing your time limit by holding up a
pin card and I would also um like to
explain that if a speaker has written
testimony to please indicate that and to
pass it to representative Walker for
distribution around the committee table
and additionally if um after the five
minute um time if you in fact do have
more information that you would like to
share with the committee then please
indicate that and then please follow up
um with written communication to the
committee via
email and um finally as a reminder when
you take the seat to provide testimony
please State for the record your name
who you represent and your position on
the
set at this time the chair will open up
the public hearing on House Bill 501 FN
relative to allowing towns to decline 5G
Towers the chair would like to recognize
representative Diane Kelly the prime
sponsor of this bill good afternoon and
welcome to Municipal and County
government good afternoon Madam chair
and members of the committee um did you
all or did some of you at least receive
the email last night um I sent photos um
regarding the 5G towers that are um part
of the discussion um the first one is in
front of the Bedford PD it's big huge
tall scary looking thing representative
Kelly could you pull the mic closer
because I'm having trouble hearing you
yeah is that better yes it is thank you
anyway um the tower in front of the um
Bedford Police Department is a rather
large one and then the newer ones which
are considerably smaller and harder to
see at the top of utility polls um
anyway um I am representative Diane
Kelly from Hillsboro District 32 and I'm
here today to introduce HB 501 a
critical piece of legislation that
empowers local communities to make
informed decisions about Wireless
infrastructure within their own borders
this bill builds upon the findings of
the New Hampshire State commission to
study the environmental and health
effects of evolving 5G technology which
is also known as the 5G commission the
commission found that the insurance
industry looks on microwave radiation
from cell towers as a hazardous
pollutant and will not ordinarily even
insure damages caused by ionizing or
non-ionizing microwave radiation the
commission further found that microwave
radiation levels are not even being
measured or documented by Dees DHHS or
any other state agency furthermore the
commission reported that while many
Studies have indicated that microwave
radiation has biological and
environmental effects on humans
protective standards for New Hampshire
Flora flora and fauna don't exist and
deserve much greater consideration and
study for these reasons I believe that
um RF RSA 12K must be amended so that
the state takes a more neutral position
on the roll out of 5G in New Hampshire
as the law currently exists City
governments face significant legal
pressure if they try to deny a cell
tower and they're unable to even address
objections from residents and business
owners around Wireless infrastructure if
the state of New Hampshire refuses to
implement the findings of the 5G
commission and has failed to regulate or
track radiation pollution levels then
the state should leave the decision of
when or where to site a cell tower up to
the individual cities and towns as we
navigate the rapidly evolving landscape
of Wireless technology it's imperative
that we balance progress with Prudence
this bill is not about halting
technological advancement but rather
it's about ensuring that the people of
this state have a voice in shaping the
landscape of their own
communities thank you for your time
thank you representative Kelly for that
bill introduction are you willing to
take questions I am however um following
me will be the um one of the directors
of the foundation for bioethics and
she's um considerably more expert at
these things and would probably do a
much better job okay questions for the
prime
sponsor seeing none thank you thank you
Crandle good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chair can you hear me okay
great good afternoon my name is Jeremy
Crandle I am here today on behalf of
ctia we are the the wireless industry
trade Association I am speaking in
opposition to House Bill 501 as
background CTI members include such
companies as American Tower AT&T
T-Mobile Verizon and US Cellular all of
which serve customers here in New
Hampshire or have wireless
infrastructure deployments in the state
in discussing this issue with you uh
before you today I want to start with
two key items uh because right now we
are seeing two things number one
unprecedented demand from consumers for
more Wireless services and the rate at
which that growth is happening is is
happening at exponential rates number
two a desire for improved connectivity
in all communities in this state now our
members are working hard to respond to
both of those items I just mentioned
investing $30 billion in 2023 alone in
private resources to upgrade and expand
the nation's networks including here in
New Hampshire but I want but I want to
speak specific to this bill because
where that investment goes that I just
mentioned and how those resources are
invested depends more than anything on
predictability especially for our
members who design and plan their
infrastructure Investments 18 to 24
months in advance speaking specifically
for New Hampshire for the last two
decades you all have had in place
Wireless sighting policies that fit
within the framework that I just talked
talked about they provide a very clear
level of predictability and they set
very clear rules of the road in terms of
Wireless permitting for both providers
and local governments very important
piece as well and in no uncertain terms
House Bill 501 would essentially
eliminate almost all of those rules the
bill effectively deletes a broad swath
of current state law governing Wireless
permitting and it would replace it with
what what are vague unclear and likely
un lawful language I want to be a little
specific about what I'm talking about
here the bill deletes these are two
examples the the bill deletes a
requirement that quote carriers should
minimize the visual impact of a wireless
facility the bill also deletes a mandate
that state law not encroach on quote a
municipality's zoning and Building Code
Enforcement Powers those are just two
examples and I'm happy to share some
others in the Q&A finally it is highly
likely that the Bill runs a foul of
federal law as well the Federal
Communications Act and the FCC the
Federal Communications Commission are es
they are both especially clear rules
from the FCC excuse me are especially
clear that states and localities cannot
pass laws that would effectively
prohibit terms of wireless service and
in practice that is what this bill does
and so for these reasons we would urge a
no vote on House Bill 501 and I will
just add Madam chair uh we did I did
well thank you Mr Crandle so with
regards to submission of written
testimony do you have
okay Miss Susi has that thank you for
passing that out and you're willing to
take questions absolutely yes questions
for Mr
Crandle representative Dolan has a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for uh taking my question question
is do you have any um independent
evidence
of uh these towers impacting uh
residents health
concerns yeah thank you for the question
so speaking to health concerns and
health effects I want to really
emphasize uh what I'm about to share it
is the consensus of both the US and
international scientific community that
there are no known adverse health
effects as a result of the level of
radio frequency energy emitted by
Wireless infrastructure uh cell phones
and wre wireless equipment the FCC has
examined and actively examines this
issue in terms of regulation of our
infrastructure the Food and Drug
Administration the World Health
Organization the NIH National Cancer
Institute have all found through their
studies over the last decade
approximately over the last decade that
there are no known adverse health
effects as it relates to this issue and
so we at ctia are going have and will
continue to trust and rely on the expert
opinion of those organizations that I
just share that I just mentioned I will
also share that ctia we have a website
www.wireless Health fact.org that
expands extensively upon what I just
said and provides a significant amount
of background information related to
those items
representative further questions
representative FR is is recognized for a
question thank you madam chair uh thank
you Mr kandle for your testimony help me
understand is there any sort of a
difference in in terms of either
intensity or the way that the microwaves
propagate between 5G and 4G or 10g that
I can buy from Comcast whatever that is
thank you for the question
representative so first and foremost I
want to emphasize for you all I'm not a
scientist um I will also add that uh a
following witness is going to focus more
on the science related to this issue but
representative I do specific to your
question do need to point back to what I
just shared a minute ago that this issue
and it's an important one has been
looked at by a range of organizations
that focus on these items specific
specifically and have come to that
conclusion that there are no known
effects additional
questions representative majori is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm trying to
reconcile in my mind line 17 of the bill
Roman five which says municipalities May
enact rules uh rules and regulations to
enforce the provisions of the section
provided that regulations are consistent
with state and federal law so doesn't
that bring us I'm wondering if that line
brings us right back
to to where we were to begin with and
therefore we why even have this
bill I would agree with you
representative um in terms of our
opposition to this bill but if if you
don't mind can I expand a little bit
upon that yes so New Hampshire's citing
statute is approximately seven pages I
have it right here in this binder um it
is extensive in terms of what it lays
out in terms of requirements on us as
providers but also very clear and
consistent range of items in terms of
responsibilities that local governments
can take and impose on us as providers
when we want to deploy our equipment I
want to share two examples very
important pieces that would be deleted
by this bill each carrier or its
appointed agent doing business or
seeking to do business in this state
shall comply with all applicable State
and Municipal land use regulation laws
that will be deleted if this bill were
to were to pass and then one other item
any person prior to constructing a new
tower in any location where no approval
is required but is visible from any
other New Hampshire municipality within
20 miles shall provide written
notification of such planned
construction to other municipalities
within that 20 mile range that would ALS
that those are two examples of items
that are in those seven pages of of New
Hampshire law right now that would be
moved and boiled down to a much smaller
package if you will uh that is House
Bill
501 yes
followup thank you so if I understand
you correctly then still would have to
comply with state and federal law but
local control would for all intent and
purpose be completely eliminated so I'm
not a lawyer so I'll def defer I want to
be careful and answering your the last
part of your question there in my
opinion here's what I want to put a fine
point on my testimony and answering your
question there is nothing in New
Hampshire law right now that and I want
to be very clear in how I'm how I'm
referring to this there's nothing in
state law right now that prevents a
locality from denying a permit for a
wireless tower or other equipment
provided that those requirements meet
the legal standards s sorry let me
rephrase that there's nothing to stop a
local government from denying a permit
based on the legal standards that they
set out in their local ordinance now
that local ordinance does need to also
comply with state state rules state
regulations and state laws federal laws
and regulations but that is no different
than any other sector or any other
industry that is regulated at the local
the state and federal level and so right
now in current law that power exists for
local government and that is why uh we
would strongly urge against making such
questions seeing none thank you thank
trelli good afternoon and welcome back
to Municipal and County government in
quite a day a man of many
hats my name is Joe trelli I'm in
Hampton New Hampshire and I have become
I am not an expert in this but I did
manage to get synchronous video and
audio from 72 countries back to 30 Rock
when I worked for NBC news so I have a
little bit of understanding of RF and
satellite dishes and
microwaves I also live in Hampton and we
just had over the last two years a
battle with vertex about putting an
oversized
Tower very close to a Runway our runway
in uh in
Hampton and so I actually took it upon
myself to go out and
navigate and representative fra asked a
little bit a while ago about doing a
PowerPoint and I did PowerPoints for the
board of Selectmen that pretty much
showed what the alternative is and what
uh what vertex was saying I'll hold it
up no viable alternative I don't know if
the camera can see that so that was the
plan that they had and presented to the
Selectmen no viable alternative to the
zoning board and to the selectman well I
disagree we have things that are called
canisters made by galtronics that can be
limited to
LTE which is six gigs and Below versus
5G which is 30 gigs up to 300 gigs of
microwave high frequency
when you go higher frequency you have
shorter distance when you have lower
frequency you have longer distance so
these canisters I will do the little
animation here and go through
it transmit receive and handoff it's LTE
lower power provision provisioned with
specific signal pattern so patterns can
be Omni directional cardioid and ribbon
okay so figure eight so this is the one
that's near the tennis court going up
from Atlantic Avenue as you're working
your way around I guess it's Church
Street uh example of ribbon cable ribbon
Willow Avenue it's called in Northampton
so that's one of them so that one that
one's in a ribbon cable so this is the G
bottom of the galtronics connector it
tells you what the frequencies are that
you're plugging in the fiber or whatever
it is to do that and this one is on
Atlantic Avenue and M Road I live on
Woodland so Woodland goes straight up
once I get up to the Pond I have
uninterrupted service all the way into
Rye because we have several of these we
have eight of these in our area and I'm
going to skip over to the uh to my map
because I did radians I did radius I did
all kinds of stuff so let's scroll up
here and I will show you the map and
this doesn't look as good as it does as
it would if this was full screen but
that's effectively Northern Hampton into
Southern North Hampton and that's where
all of these canisters are mounted at
the top of the utility pole okay so I'm
showing a 25 uh uh quarter mile radius
with the little blue marks and there's
not a lot of overlap it's LTE longer
distance you provision it with LTE you
boost the power a little bit and you go
to a half a mile and I don't know if you
can see this but the red the red crosses
over pretty much all of the area so
these have been installed TNT is the one
that I am pretty sure has done it I can
watch the signal strength go up on my
regular phone watch it drop off as I get
closer at to the range the range
limitation and then it picks up again
which is what it's supposed to do and
that's what handoffs do so I don't want
Towers I think 5G is pretty much old
already as we get into technology and
things are starting to move a little bit
faster with with what Comcast is doing
with their little cylinders that are
hanging between the utility point s that
are effectively neighborhood Wi-Fi is
what they called it in 2013 when they
started doing that so when you drive
around you're going to see a a like a
cylinder hanging from the utility wire
the cable and a bunch of cables goes in
on one side that's effectively a big
Wi-Fi so I'm going to wrap it up and I
said four minutes I'm at
4:15 thank you Mr trelli questions for
the
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
very
Thatcher good afternoon sir and welcome
to Municipal and County government thank
you uh Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Andrew Thatcher and
I'm here at the request of
ctia and I am also in opposition to the
bill I just submitted written testimony
but I'd actually like to jump straight
to his question and comment and just
kind of work through a little bit better
exactly what 5G is so we all understand
the playing field we're talking about so
fifth generation Evolution what we're
talking about as opposed to 2G
4G or 3G what have you covers a number
of different frequency bands 600
megahertz 800 2 .5 GHz 3.5 GHz 5.5 GHz
are the line and share of what 5G is
that's what's being deployed just about
everywhere and those
frequencies as far as biologically are
no different than the 4G and 3G or UHF
for that we've used in TV Etc so those
frequencies have been around a very very
long time and fundamentally
biophysically they're no different than
and than everything that we're used to
so at least in the state of New
Hampshire I think a lot of the concern
with 5G people immediately jump to a
higher frequency the millimeter waves
which can be at least in use in the US
can be 24 28 gahz 37 39 gigahertz
there's some higher frequency bands that
are being developed but they're not in
use yet so 37 gigahertz is about as high
as we get most of the concern really
seems to be about these millimeter waves
the higher frequencies of
which uh usually are only used in high
density population districts like uh
like Boston or New York or something
like that is where you're going to see
those there's a possibility in New
Hampshire I would say so I would never
rule it out but maybe in a big
university you might want a little bit
of that in the campus Because you've
just got too many people um but by and
large most of that as the gentleman
before me had mentioned is handled by
the small cells that's typically done
and they do use 5G but it could be for
AT&T it's going to be like 3.5 GHz I
mean Wii networks even in my own house
use 2.4 and 5.5 GHz so these are not
frequencies that we're not unfamiliar
with um going to the 5G millimeter wave
just talking about the physics for the
that uh those
antennas are amazingly tiny so you may
have an antenna panel that's about this
big and it could have 128 antennas on
there that are all about that big they
put out about a tenth of a watt so
diminishingly small energy only because
as opposed to a traditional antenna
which is just broadcasting
uniformly you're you get one if you're
in use and you're using a phone that
antenna would be direct directed toward
you and you only so if there was someone
right next to you okay they might get an
exposure but it's exceedingly small but
if any further distance away you're not
getting any exposure at all so from
someone who does measurements and does
analysis for a living from all of the
antennas be rooftops or what have you
the 5G millimeter wave contribution is
diminishingly small so we've got very
little power from those millimeter waves
the attenuation because the the
frequency is so high it actually doesn't
penetrate the outer layer of the skin
that's it so we're worried about or
people worried about gosh I'm worried
about adverse health effects and I will
admit there's not a ton of information
or science on studies on the higher
millimeter waves there's quite a bit but
not as much as what we have for
everything else but from a physics
standpoint there really is no reason for
us to think
that there could be a mechanism for
which harm could happened because we're
limited to the skin and the eyes for
those and the basis of the standards is
limiting tissue Heating and the heating
over the last 70 years is the only known
mechanism of harm it's just pure energy
where and how you mod modulate a 5G or
4G signal or something really doesn't
matter to the cellular level because
it's just pure physics it's just pure
energy so uh as opposed to Jumping
further into it I just was kind of
trying to lay out the groundwork for
what 5G why millimeter
waves I mean they're new but I mean in
the big picture in the 70s I can
remember that uh microwave ovens holy
cow we're putting cancer boxes in our
kitchens and No One Believes that
anymore in the '90s and early 2000s I
was RF expert for the state of
Washington for 20 years um and uh the
big concern of course was uh these could
cause cancer but as a physicist I that
was pretty easy to find out but we have
a tremendous amount of information to
now show that of course it doesn't cause
cancer and we have the human St studies
to back that up and I'm done I guess so
I'll open up for questions thanks for
your time thank you Mr thater questions
oh representative frock has a question
raise your hand higher not just a
finger thank you madam chair uh Mr
Thatcher my question may be uh a little
out of your area of
expertise but I'm I'm intrigued what the
previous speaker Mr Chelli um informed
us about uh these cans on utility polls
as an alternative to Towers now now we
in my town uh couple of years ago we
permitted a tower for it was either
three or four different
carriers my question
is do the do these
cans uh have the ability to carry
signals for multiple carriers or are
they limited to single carriers that's a
great question typically and I work for
a lot of utilities for implementation of
these cuz you can imagine they're on
light poles or power poles or what have
you um buy a general rule most utilities
limit one carrier per pole so if you
want to do small sales is what they're
called in a different neighborhood pick
a different poll so typically speaking
you're only going to have and if there's
one antenna or one canister that can
only be one carrier because they're
they're broadcasting out on their
allowed channels so you'd have to have
another antenna and there would be a
little bit of Separation but generally
speaking for small cells it's one for
one because there's plenty of lights or
there's plenty of power poles you can go
somewhere else so does that answer it it
does I I have a followup Madam chair
will allow yes I'll allow
um can you compare the cost of r a rural
deployment of service in a
hypothetical let's say 10 m square area
using a single Tower versus these cans
which is more cost effective I'm
definitely not the cost person but what
I basically it comes down to efficiency
if you have one tower for this large
area there's only so many callers it can
handle so much data it can handle so
they end up having to deploy more more
areas locally in order to to cover to
make sure we get the coverage as Jeremy
mentioned the use is going up quite a
bit so typically what's that's what's
going on and and as far as exposures Go
I mean I've been doing survey since the
90s uh and the background radio
frequency background basically really
hasn't changed since the 80s or 90s it
basically stays the same uh as we get
more densification
uh the power levels and overall
background tends to go down because they
can't broadcast that further than just
the area they're trying to cover
otherwise they lose efficiencies in the
design further questions representative
Dolan has a question thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question my question is into your uh
expertise of physics SL Electronics
often times
communities uh get a tower and the fire
department says hey can I put my antenna
on the tower and then the police
department says I want to put one up two
and then and then you've got different
Technologies uh at probably at different
frequencies can you comment on any uh
stacking of frequencies or right or um I
do a lot of that work actually for the
the utilities fire departments Etc so
I'm very familiar in fact I've got two
on my desk doing projects towers that
include everybody typically the fire
department uh police stations Etc are
using more like a 400 megahertz or 500
MHz that's that's typically a frequency
you're going to use if we're using like
you say push to talk or handheld
walkie-talkie or something like that
that's that's typically common um all of
the antennas I don't care who makes them
are required to go through FCC
verification and Val validation and that
is to make sure that if this is your
bandwidth you know 10 to 15 mahz or
whatever it is you don't exceed that you
don't spill over into something else so
so yes they can all I I do Towers where
there's there's eight or 10 different
sites on it if it's big enough uh and
they'll have a lot of different carriers
and a lot of different uses typically
speaking those fire departments or the
police and radio Etc don't have a lot of
the duty cycle is much smaller meaning
you're not having constant transmission
you're having individual intermittent so
it tends to not be 100% transmission so
you back further
questions had a quick question so with
regards to the 5G millimeter
wavelengths you in your testimony stated
that um there's no evidence that it
causes heating o of the skin and I don't
think I said that oh no I said That's
the basis of the standard is the tissue
heating so as long as we're less than
the limits we won't cause that tissue
heating so okay so what I was trying to
understand so I misunderstood what you
had said but what I was trying to
understand is do we know if there's any
evidence that that there's at the
cellular level with regards to bonds
like for example DNA RNA can can the
electromagnetic energy affect th those
bonds at that very small cellular level
of thank you for that question I
probably meant to mention that and that
here in front of you I I forget
so ultraviolet light about 10 Electro
electron volts is the minimum energy
necessary to cause DNA strand breakage
or damage uh everybody knows about skin
cancer etc etc really what's going on in
the DNA
strand following an exp exposure you can
get a stickiness and you could have a
thing called like a thyine dier where
two strands would stick together and if
you're trying to replicate well you
could have a misrep so that's that's
really the minimum energy by which this
genetic damage that you speak of Could
Happen uh these millimeter waves were
about a 100,000 times less than that so
I don't care how much power you're using
you're not going to cause genetic damage
what you can could do especially if it's
a millimeter wave and it were high
enough intensity you could get an athema
A skin rening right your skin got hot or
something because of an intense exposure
but
again we we're nowhere near the
proximity and I do a lot of rooftop work
so that's predominantly where I am but
um you're just as long as we're less
than those standards we're not going to
even get an athema because that would be
a really high exposure to be honest with
you but even then move your hand away
back away for a few minutes and your
blood flow and radiative heat loss Will
Will dissipate that
energy did that help yes it did thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you
appreciate your time thank
you next the chair recognizes Miss
Brittney D Bernard D
Bernardo good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
afternoon honorable members of the
municipal and County government
committee U my name is Britney D
Bernardo and I'm a resident of Franklin
New Hampshire and I would like to talk
about the
harms of the 5G in our community the New
Hampshire 5G report that was funded by
New Hampshire tax dollars nearly 5 years
ago was a breaking document and I
support HB 51 because I believe for the
sake of New Hampshire's public health
and environment we need to re visit that
document and execute its recommendations
currently under RSA 12- K10 IV it states
that an authority may not mandate
require or regulate the installation
location or use of personal wireless
service
facilities this term is outlined in RSA
12K and includes both Standalone 5G
towers as well as those placed on
utility
poles this is a massive oversight and
encourages the Telecom industry to
install these personal wireless service
facilities on utility polls where there
is no permit or public discourse
required prior to their placement it is
imperative that Authority is restored to
Municipal governments and to the people
of New Hampshire whether to accept the
risks outlined in the 5G report or stand
up and decline personal Wireless
Services facilities in our
communities thank you for your
time thank you Miss b d Bernardo will
are you willing to take questions um at
this time I have someone with me Josie
who is much better at answering those
questions okay thank
fabrio good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and government good afternoon
as well chair power Vice chair McDonald
and members of the committee thank you
for letting me speak today I am Rick
Fabrizio uh senior director of advocacy
and public affairs for the business and
industry Association we are New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
and leading nonpartisan business
Advocate Bia opposes House Bill 501 and
we LED efforts to defeat flawed bills
the last three years that sought to
unreasonably rest strict Wireless
telecommunications in New Hampshire
because it's critical to Residents
businesses first uh responders and the
state economy allowing municipalities to
decline 5G Towers would increase the
risk of running a file of the federal
Telecommunications Act specifically
section 704 in multiple areas HB 501
would also repeal the New Hampshire law
rsk RSA 12K regarding personal wireless
service facilities the this law promotes
smaller alternatives to the taller
cellular towers and it's critical
ensuring First Responders are able to
collocate antennas on towers for
wireless emergency
communications municipalities already
have sign significant ability to uh site
personal Wireless facilities and Towers
uh permitted by the Telecommunications
Act HB 501 even states that decisions to
deny why 5 Wireless facilities shall be
made in accordance with state and
federal law and
regulations now HP 501 is also at odds
with the state policy to facilitate the
provision of broadband and wire Advanced
Wireless personal Advanced personal
Wireless services and uh also to promote
its access to Residents students
government agencies and businesses given
the critical importance to the economy
and everyday life nowadays the constant
in the opposition to the bills the last
now four years has been uh the
allegations that 5G causes health
effects uh as has been pointed out
electromagnetic radio frequency W waves
are nonionizing meaning they don't have
the energy to damage uh DNA or cause
direct tissue damage I have included in
my written testimony a long list of
State uh and health agencies uh that do
not support allegations of causation uh
health effects by um 5G and other
telecommunications Wireless
telecommunications um in conclusion we
ask the committee to find H HB 501
inexpedient to legislate and I'm happy
to take any questions and try to answer
them for you thank you Mr Fabrizio are
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank
good afternoon and welcome to Municipal
and County government good afternoon
ma'am thank you for having me and
testimony my name is Josie kundala and I
live in Dover New Hampshire my interest
in this bill is derived from my
experience with the city of Manchester
where I lived for the past two years
last year I contacted Manchester's
zoning health and planning departments
about a small Wireless Communications
facility installed near my home in a
public right of way the city denied
having any knowledge of the tower
because they do not regulate or even
keep track of the locations of any
antenna employed in the public right of
way um I believe uh representative Kelly
provided a photo of a small one this is
the one near my home on Woodberry Street
in New Hampshire uh Manchester New
Hampshire um and they the reason that um
the city uh told me that they couldn't
uh track or even document or uh do
anything about these facilities is RSA
12K um the law is it's currently Rootin
states that carriers wishing to build
personal wireless service facilities in
New Hampshire should consider
commercially available alternative pwss
that's personal W wireless service
facility over tall cell towers and
further down in uh 12 K10 section 4 It
also says that notwithstanding anything
to the contrary in this chapter an
authority may not mandate require or
regulate the installation location or
use of pwss on utility polls um so that
is why I'm here this is the aggravation
that I've personally dealt with um in
dealing with my City's um uh zoning
officials um so I'm here to tell you
that whether a wireless facil facility
is on a utility poll or it's 60 feet in
the air um it's still emitting microwave
radiation and they should be regulated
in the same way um 12K is trying to
address the aesthetic objections um The
View uh impairments that tall cell
towers um represent and I understand
that many uh residents in small towns
don't like seeing cell towers in their
Vistas but my personal objection has to
do with the fact um which is uh detailed
in the 5G report that um non-ionizing
radiation is an uninsurable pollutant
and the entire insurance industry is
hedging against 5G um this was all
detailed in the 5G report in 2020 and
since that time um the U FCC has been
sued under Environmental Health Trust
versus FCC in 2021 and the federal judge
declared that the sec's standards were
capricious and arbitrary in terms of
their exposure guidelines for microwave
radiation so for these reasons um and
because the New Hampshire State
Legislature has already established a 5G
commission and their investigation
concluded that there is sufficient
evidence of biological and environmental
effects from these antenna um that this
um legislature should remove or amend
their laws and they have not done that
since the establishment of the 5G
Commission Now if the state does not
wish to be active um on the topic
microwave radiation regulation then they
should leave the matter to local
constituents and um health and planning
boards that's my position um this bill
does not in any way overrule federal
policy or take away anyone's uh right to
access services or for providers to meet
the demand for services there are
already ample cell towers um throughout
the state um Na nasua and Manchester are
headlong in the deployment of these
small Wireless facilities um but unlike
um residents of smaller towns who might
have an objection to a cell tower to in
their view if you are a resident of a
place like Manchester or nashaa or
Hampton where the small Wireless uh
towers are being deployed you have no
you no means uh either by planning board
Selectmen zoning Health Department none
of those uh regulatory bodies can
address your issues even though the
state has admitted that the harms and
Hazards exist in the 5G report so for
that reason I'm asking the committee to
review the 5G report and to begin to
implement some of its recommendations of
which uh HB 501 is a good start thank
you thank you are you willing to take
speaker no seeing none thank you thank
much next the chair recognizes Mr Henry
vu
thank you madam chair um Mr Crandle
Thatcher andio covered a lot of things I
was GNA say so I will just submit the V
sir next the chair recognizes Mr Eric
power
good afternoon and welcome back to
Municipal and County
government thank you Madame chair and
members of the municipal and County
government committee for the record my
name is Eric power I'm from Brooklyn
representing myself and in favor of
House Bill
501 um as I mentioned previously I serve
on the planning board in Brookline been
serving on it since
2021 going into my fifth year uh
I also am a electrical engineer I have a
um a background in RF and background in
electronic warfare for over three
decades um I have a bachelor's degree
from Wester poly Technic Institute in
electrical engineering and also a
master's degree in electrical
engineering from nor Eastern University
uh I am a senior member of the uh
Institute for electronics and electrical
engineers the i e so I've had a lot of
experience with RF and it's definitely
something that you have to consider that
it's we don't know all the answers right
now um 5G by its nature if you go back
to physics the the very path loss
formula for physics shows that the uh
the path loss that means how much the
signal attenuates is if is it inversely
proportional to the square of the
frequency so the higher you go in
frequency at the square of that you're
going down in power so if you need to
keep Communications and you're going up
higher in frequency what do you think
you have to do with the power you have
to go up a lot to actually establish
that now some modulation and some coding
can definitely um take care of that and
um but you know the proliferation of
these without and putting my planning
board hat back on being able not to be
able to say or have anything to do with
these personal Wireless uh facilities is
being put in on right of ways I think is
wrong the 5G commission talked about
that RSA 12K let you do that now and I
think that that this uh bill is is a is
a good bill to help bring that local
control back we have a lot of money and
a lot of business interest here I'm not
here for that I'm here for the the
residents of my town and the residents
of the state to do the right thing and
make sure that we have control and that
we understand what's going on right now
we do not have the millimeter wave um 5G
deployed here much in New Hampshire but
that's going to that is going to be
coming if if you don't take action um
and we do not know what's going to
happen for those that aren't aware um
microwave ovens run at 2.4 gigahertz
that's where you cook your food so you
know keep that in mind it has higher
power levels but it's we use microwave
to cook food and you can you know what
does to food it Heats it up and and it
Cooks it right so um the other thing I'd
like to mention is the there's going to
be a tendency to go to these higher
carriers because at higher carriers you
have higher bandwidth and at higher
bandwidth you have more capacity so the
the market is going to drive the
adoption of these higher gigahertz level
you know 30 gigahertz and above
standards and they're not here yet but
we have a chance to do things the right
way with having local control and if if
this bill was to pass in my role on the
planning board I would be able to use my
technical knowledge as along with the
local control that we have to make
Intelligent Decisions on these Wireless
facilities before it's too late and they
proliferate everywhere you've heard from
prior speakers that it's already
starting to roll out in Manchester and
in Nashville and maybe in some other
urban areas this is the time to um to
pull back the Reign on this a little bit
and to um you know pass House Bill 501
in order to make reasonable control and
if you look at paragraphs four and five
of the bill it says we cannot do
anything that violates state or federal
regulation so we're not going to be able
to do anything we can't do by federal
law so we're going to be bound by that
so I think it has the safeguards that we
need and I hope that you find it a to
pass thank you very much I'll take
questions are there any questions for
the
you oh the last pink card that I have is
The
Gart good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
afternoon thank you Committee just I
don't want to be um disrespectful but
the The Honorable title thing I just I
just shy away from me it gets kind of
weird to me so but I do thank I do thank
you for that and I'm here today to speak
about a bill that I think is very
important I brought a bill last year to
implement the recommendations from the
5G commission that was instituted in
2020 that we already mentioned but a lot
of time and energy has gone into this
issue New Hampshire was the first state
and if you look up 5G effects and
dangers and so forth online that comes
up everywhere and I do believe that New
Hampshire again has to take the lead and
start really addressing an issue that we
haven't looked at since
1996 so let me explain now I just want
to set the scene here 1996 Independence
Day was a movie in the theaters twister
really garbage movie but among also
the um what do we
have I'm sorry I lost my train thought
with that twister was such a bad movie
but the FCC has not changed their
Wireless radiation human exposure limits
since 1996 despite a court case the 2021
US court of appeals for District of
Columbia judgment in environmental
health trusts at all versus the FCC
found that the fcc's refusal to update
its 1996 limits to be quote arbitrary
and capricious end quote because it
ignored the science on children's
vulnerability on long-term exposure on
non-cancer impacts such as damage to
memory and sperm on environmental
impacts birds bees trees Etc and the
hundreds of testimonies submitted by
people reporting injuries now this is
from an article from Environmental
Health Trust which is a great website
has a lot of good data info Graphics you
can kind of just for somebody like me
with ad helps you kind of just you know
keep busy and find out what's going on
but this is also mentioning the Ohio
lawmakers that wrote letters to the FCC
saying hey we want to know what these
new limits are 1996 was a long time ago
I was 11 years old a lot has changed
cell phones were not nearly as
ubiquitous as they are today and a lot
of other techn
ology as long along with the governor of
Wyoming in 2022 is I mean there's a ton
of people that submitted letters to the
FC and so forth but we haven't gotten
anywhere now hopefully with the new make
America healthy again movement I'm
hoping that does occur but I think we
also need to take that at the local
level and this is what this does You're
simply saying local entities do what you
wish according to the wishes of your
will of your constituents who to be
quite honest with you I think people in
general know the truth better than
certain people who are not able to
devote as much time to this to this
subject and other things for instance
the committee you guys are tired it's a
long day someone's coming on five
o'clock how many people really going to
you know do a little extra credit work
homework tonight and look into this and
I don't blame you I didn't do much
myself but I do know on Edna that I
served last term every year apparently
every two years the fire codes
representative D knows the fire codes
get updated the building codes get
updated they were trying to push some
new environmental you know uh reducing I
mean increasing the insulation on houses
drive up the cost further but that stuff
happens every other year we have to do
it I still don't understand why we have
to do it because the fire commissioner
sorry Fire Marshall for the state
admitted that there's no real proof that
the fire code actually there's no metric
to show that it's saving lives or
affecting anything it's just something
we do because everybody's doing it so I
would say that you know since 1996 maybe
this is something we should be doing at
the state level we did with the 5G
Commission so I'm encouraging you to
support this
legislation and hopefully we can get to
the bottom of what's going on and I just
want to let you know that I did I just
happen to glance on my mailbox usually I
throw away all this stuff but from a
former speaker his organization put out
the legislative report of 2024 and I
just looked at on the cover because
mentioned 5G Bill killed again but in
that article you know little fluff piece
anyway various polls consistently show
New Hampshire residents support Mobile
Wireless upgrades in their Community
including small cell antennas which are
essential for 5G deployment right
outside the bedroom windows I didn't say
that but the point is why do we have 100
people Plus in support of this bill and
I believe it was like 15 to 20 maybe you
guys will mention that at the end I
don't think people are in support of
this as much as the industry paid
lobbyists are trying to tell us and I
think we have serious problems and we
need to look at it and trust people that
the 5G commission just look at the
report I mean 600 pages but just look at
the recommendations is a lot of effort
went in and I really think we should we
should move on this so thank
you thank you Mr G geard are there
questions representative Elward is
recognized for a
question thank you Madame chairman good
to see you good to see you thank you do
you
think average members of planning
boards have the technical background
education uh
experience to
industry I would argue that planning
boards and and everything in that realm
of central planning reminds me of some
kind of weird stalinesque dystopian
Nightmare and I'm not really a big fan
of that what I'm disappointed in just F
off that what I'm disappointed in is
that the average person does not really
have any way to to stop let's say a
small cell antenna outside their bedroom
window in a city so that's all I got to
questions see seeing none thank you so
that was the last pink card that we
have and repres um chair Vice
chairman Vice chairman McDonald will
report out the blue sheet I think I'm a
little tired okay and uh today's blue
sheet we have one for the bill and five
against
thank you and with that the chair will
close the public hearing on House Bill
FN so that concludes our publicly
noticed business for today before we
adjourn I have a few um afternoon
announcements so the committee will meet
on Monday March 3rd for hearings and
executive sessions that has been
scheduled please plan for a house
session to be held on Thursday March 6
additionally please hold open Monday
March 10th for executive sessions only
this date will become
official once it's been scheduled and
publicly noticed are there any
questions
no what
their house session on Thursday March
6th yeah okay so seeing Oh representa
France are are we having hearings on
Monday as well I only have executive
session so that that's been scheduled
and publicly noticed and yes there are
hearings in the morning on the remaining
bills and that have been referred to
this committee and following that after
lunch we will be um holding executive
sessions on several bills so it's both
yeah any further
questions okay seeing none the meeting
is now adjourned thank you and have a